Recording and we're back,
you know,
can't get annoyed.
Really.
It's amazing that this can even happen at all.
It's amazing that the fucking kitchen table in my office connected to Time
Warner cable or whatever the fuck I've got can do that.
That's amazing.
Anyway,
so it's amazing in the first place that this is even possible.
So if every 128th episode,
an audio input fries on the laptop,
I should be fucking amazed at that stupid thing.
Put out a 127 episodes.
Yeah,
you don't have to have a 200 foot antenna on your roof.
It's,
I show up somewhere.
It's like we're like Christian Slater and pump up the volume side
to be like,
like fucking art bell living out there and pull romp Nevada.
You ever seen that guy's house?
Dude?
It's the coolest shit ever.
But our bell is right out of a goddamn movie.
If you don't know who he is.
Art Bell was the dude who he had this late night radio show.
He still does it,
I think on the weekends.
Right?
But he had it.
He did it every night.
For a while called coast to coast am and you could not shake art bell,
you could call him up art.
I'm aware of Wolf.
Really.
How long have you been aware of Wolf?
Who would just go along with that?
But he will never find me.
Come on.
Of course he has questions but he will never questioned you.
He will,
I mean he will question you who asks you questions but it'll never ridicule you
or cast judgment on your craziness.
And so because of that,
he would just get one nutty mother fucker after another,
calling him up with crazy predictions and all kinds of nutty shit about the
Mayans and 2012 and mind control and you FO's house for all things,
all things crazy.
It was great though.
It's the perfect time to deliver to that shit is when it was on,
it was on from like,
I think 10:00 PM at night until like two in the morning or something like that.
You looks to her bad listener as a kid and just listened to me like the best.
Yeah,
like guys like that.
And then,
um,
uh,
Dr Demento like guys who are just carve out little niches for themselves as
well.
For me,
no,
there's no comparison.
Our bells,
the kangaroo because our belt,
I always knew that I would get some sort of juicy,
crazy talk,
you know,
that I could be listening to on the way home.
But all the sexy stuff you have folds,
bigfoot,
anything sexy.
Didn't you fall in love with that shit though?
Like A,
and I remember as a kid,
you listened to the radio.
It's like a real intimate thing when you're just listening to something cause
you just go off because all your other senses just chill out and you go off to
another place and you're part of it.
You're in the discussion to the point where you almost saying shit and like why
dance dancer and me,
I think this podcast is just like that too.
It's better.
It's better in audio form I think.
And it's a beeline to,
to the people,
like there's an intimacy or I'm finding with,
you know,
even my podcasts,
like the intimacy and,
and,
and nice plug by the way,
but he's Lockhart has a podcast on death squad,
squad.tv and it's called a what's good?
Well,
let's go to the Freddy Lockhart and you've done three of them so far,
right?
But it's like a sun.
It's like the loyalty of your listeners.
And I'm talking to people from Finland,
Australia.
It's like I never even thought I would even those people,
like they're feeling what we're saying and they're sharing things and it's just
like,
it's so cool that we have the ability to do this now.
And it's cool that what we're doing,
the way we're doing it too is that we're all doing it together.
You know,
it's,
um,
Brian runs this death squad podcast network and it's all our friends.
It's,
it's Freddie,
it's Thompson Jura.
It's Ari should fear.
It's a Sam Tripoli.
It's funny people and it's all funny fucking,
and it's free and it's on all the time.
And it connects everybody with everybody else.
And everybody gets to know about a guy like Sam Tripoli or know about a guy like
Freddy Loc or Nova,
and we get to introduce our fans to each other in a way that you would never be
able to do on morning radio or anything,
man.
And that's what it's cool.
It's like,
I would love to get to where you're at to not ever have to do radio again
because it's like you have the most amazing thing ever.
It's never a,
there's never been a time in my career ever.
Or I could sell a theater or a club or just with people that I communicate with
online and it's fun and you don't have fun.
It's fun and it's free and they like it and you're giving them something.
It's for me,
it feels like a real honest exchange.
Like I liked the fact that it doesn't cost anything.
I want you to just was,
we're having fun and enjoy this shit and,
and,
you know,
and I think it,
it does good.
It's got,
it's,
it's sets out a good mindset.
It makes when I was a kid,
I always imitated the way other people behaved on TV.
If I thought it was cool,
you know,
I always wanted to be like that guy.
I wanted to be like this kind of movie.
It's absolutely normal.
You know?
And if you,
if you have a podcast where you can get out there to people,
a way of thinking that's not necessarily mainstream way of thinking,
that's,
you know,
thought out by a bunch of really honest,
smart people who have stepped back and really analyze this and compared notes.
You know,
we've all,
all of us have our different ways about life,
but we all,
uh,
you know,
one of the cool things about having a group of smart friends is,
if say if I want to talk to you about some shit that you experienced,
some shit that I have no knowledge of.
No.
I know I can sit down and go,
Freddy,
tell me about fishing off this p or tell me and you'll,
you'll just give me the straight dope and it'd be like,
I knew it myself,
you know,
thing in our group.
I think we all are mindful of,
you know,
I won't speak about something unless I can speak and tell him.
We all know that there's actual,
you get benefit from admitting that you don't know something.
And then being honest,
like people respect that in like that way more than you pretending.
You know what you don't know.
Right.
Oh absolutely.
No benefit to it.
It's,
it's,
it's a trick.
It's something that you got stuck doing when you were a little kid and you
stayed with it.
None of us do any of that.
The only time I still lie though is when somebody starts telling me about a
movie and they're like,
did you ever see that one?
I saw just still they'll stop.
So they'll stop.
Cause if you don't cause then they'll tell you.
They'll give you the backstory on it.
Whoops.
Was that me?
Yeah,
it works.
Sound good?
No,
but always complaining.
Yup.
That's crazy.
As this was laptop the whole time.
Yeah.
Well we had a buzzing noise at one episode.
Length should be amazed at that fucking piece of shit.
That little 13 inch wonky one.
Yeah.
And we,
you know,
there's gotta be some bad Karma to the fact that these people that are making
these laptops and computers are all working in these factories where they have
dormitories and fucking suicide nets all over the place.
Have you seen that shit,
man,
that's got,
um,
does that freak you out man,
it freaked me out.
I mean,
I know that they say,
well,
these have the best work conditions and you know,
we've provided them with counseling.
Look,
they have a billiards hall to play in.
They still seem like slaves still seems something crazy.
You got a bunch of people living in a warehouse and then they're working x
amount of hours a day for fucking 25 cents an hour or something crazy like that.
Their lives.
What are they getting paid?
Turning a product and that,
yeah,
it's weird whether you're paid or not.
If your life is devoted to making a product,
if you're now an industrialized part of machinery,
you know what I mean?
That's,
you're a slave.
You're,
you're,
you're enslaved.
W willing workers who,
where there's no work.
See in America,
we have a lot of really fucking shit jobs that nobody wants.
But in,
in China,
I think the difference is when you get to like around a billion people,
there's places where there's no options and these people were willing workers,
but they're really,
their,
their environment sucks so bad.
There's no options but to work for these factories.
And so they,
they're forced into that situation.
It's not sort of like America,
there's more opportunity to move around.
There's more different shit,
more variety,
at least as far as,
as China has been explained to me.
You know,
there's like terribly poor places that are just frightening.
No,
I've never been there.
But there's also incredible amount of rich people too.
Someone said that in Shanghai there's over a hundred thousand millionaires.
I believe it.
There's 28 million people live in there.
So it's like per capita that's,
we have 100,000 millionaires.
And you know,
the thing about China too is the,
the big point is they are not trying to take over the world.
They're trying to sell you shit.
Okay?
They're trying to make money.
They're trying to do business.
That's what they're trying to do.
The Chinese aren't trying to take over the world.
You know,
they've had their issues with ty.
They've had their issues with,
uh,
with,
with Thailand and they've had their issues with,
you know,
uh,
with,
um,
where's the Dalai Lama from Tibet.
Tibet.
Sorry to be,
yeah,
there's a lot of shit with Tibet,
right?
There's always a free Tibet bumper sticker.
So China's not innocent in a abroad,
but when you look at like how much we're involved in shit in other parts of the
world,
he just,
the economic impact of all this fucking military action.
It's staggering.
You know,
we don't consider it and we say,
Oh,
look at China blowing up.
Well,
you're trying to blow it up.
It doesn't have to worry about fucking taken over the world.
China doesn't have to worry about that.
China,
China doesn't,
you know,
they're not invested and I mean a little bit.
I'm sure they are,
but they're not invested nearly as much as we are.
And this shit.
Well,
I think they take into the old school way of thinking was it's like even in the
fourth it's like he with the nukes is the winner,
but what they've realized is this is the new era.
We all got nukes.
You know what I mean?
You pull the trigger,
we're all going down.
So the way to get ahead is to be an economical superpower.
It's fucking truly amazing that that's how it's still run in 2011 it really is
like a weapon that can kill you thing.
The handle a weapon.
It's,
well,
it's not just that.
I mean it always was a weapon that can kill you.
It used to be I had a sword and then it was,
I have a spear.
Then as I have a canon and it's still,
I have some shit that will kill you.
It's still,
I mean basically it's the same dynamic.
All comes down to that one carnal instinct.
I'll kill you.
It's amazing control of resources.
Give me the resources,
I'll fucking kill you if you're the shit.
It's amazing.
Now 2011 I wonder if it's going to be able to continue this way because it seems
like the tolerance that people have for it today is,
is very short.
It's very different than it was a few decades ago.
Did very different than it was before the Internet.
To me,
I think people think of war as much more distasteful people or if anyone is
likely to buy into any wacky conspiracy theory.
The big one would be that the military industrial complex has their fingers in
all parts of the world for making money and they force wars.
It sounds crazy,
but if you look at Eisenhower's speech and if you look at all the evidence that
that's exactly what they do,
that's a conspiracy that more people would be willing to buy.
Right?
That almost any other wacky conspiracy,
that war is big business.
Of course we forced them.
That's a fringe idea,
man.
I mean that's not something that you could bring up on CBS news and they'll just
let you slide with that.
You know,
the challenge is it's a fringe idea,
but it's one of these things where I,
is it so much fringe or just unpopular as popular to say on TV,
it's unpopular to look at reality.
It's unpopular.
Look that we are living inside the balls of the Dick that's fucking the world
and that's what's going down.
Well,
people don't want to know that.
They don't want to think about it.
They want to thank USA USA.
They don't want to think of what does that mean?
Yeah.
You,
yes.
If you and USAA and main USA,
you're talking about dudes,
right?
Bad ass books and dudes who sing great songs and people who make bad ass houses
and real American ingenuity and craftsmanship and construction.
Yes.
Go USA,
right?
Yeah.
Go Go.
All the comics that have ever come out of America go,
all of the movie makers go on.
I mean,
you want to talk creativity.
There's brilliant artists all over the world or what a fucking pool of on there
are here with a Mac.
What?
What an amazing fucking country.
This is this,
but not the military.
That fucking runs our shit,
not them.
They're not us.
That's money.
That's all.
What that is is a virus.
It's a virus that runs on money and that virus is killing people left and right,
and it might as well be a fucking disease.
It might as well be the plague or super aids or gonorrhea,
but it's a fucking virus and that virus is,
it needs money.
It's a virus fueled by money and it's willing to kill.
But how much of a of our budget do we,
a lot.
So it's a huge amounts of money and then an absurd amount.
If we kind a quarter of it,
like we'd be doing completely fine too.
Whatever arenas.
A lot.
It doesn't make any sense.
And it's like we're addicted to it.
We're addicted to be in these,
in these conflicts.
It really is.
Like Eisenhower said,
Eisenhower predicted this shit and whatever the fuck it was,
the the,
there was a FDR.
People always said too that he was trying to keep us out of World War II,
but that wasn't the case at all.
He made one real poignant speech even before the chaps that attacked Pearl
Harbor and he said something like,
if we don't,
we can't rest on our laurels and,
and,
and this is a summation,
but we can't rest on our laurels and relaxed here in our own country.
We have to go find it.
Povey opposing flows overseas if we want to feel safe here.
Which was basically like,
hey,
prepare America.
This is big business,
this fucking war.
And it was,
it was big business.
It made us,
it gave us money and invented the suburbs.
It was huge fucking business that war,
war bonds and all that shit.
But it's like now it's not a lucrative business like it used to be.
What's lucrative is the contracts,
they get to build the shit they get to justify the money they're going to spend
next year.
So it's like we keep giving all this fucking money to this thing for that sky is
falling thing when the sky isn't falling.
There was that movie gung Ho with Michael Keaton member that 1996 and there was
a quote in there and he said the American spirit is alive and alive and well
it's just in Hong Kong right now.
And it's like that was,
you know,
it was very prophetic because it is because over in China they're just like,
you know what?
Let's build shit.
Let's be,
let's just make shit.
Let's keep fucking making it like we used to do.
You know?
And the most disappointing part about it is that a lot of these guys,
a lot of the troops,
a lot of the people that are,
that are all working for,
you know,
what they believe is a good cause.
You know,
these are,
these are real heroes,
man.
I mean there are some real fucking heroes in this country volunteering,
willing to go to other parts of the world to protect the people that are back
here.
That's legit.
Yeah,
they're legit heroes.
They're just getting used by people with bad intentions.
Shirts this as clearly as as it is today.
People are doing their bidding there.
There's no doubt the American military is fucking amazing.
If they were just used for defense and just used,
you know,
for good,
it would be the most incredible force ever.
I think our,
our hall
I our biggest asset as we can bring war to any corner of the globe and in less
than 24 hours,
you're done.
We don't have the biggest,
we just got,
we got the biggest weapons and we got it.
We
can have everything.
We got military in over a hundred countries.
Our installments were,
we were like France used to be Nigga,
we everywhere.
It's more than ridiculous.
No one's ever been like this.
No one's ever had this kind of presence in the world.
I mean,
this is the United States of the world.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
Everybody else is like our little buddy who's our neighbor who yells at us,
but you know,
he knows that will burn this fucking house.
Yeah.
You put,
you know what it is.
We're,
we're a compilation of all of them and act like where these elitist,
separatist and all that,
but we're the where they all start lineup of the world.
Well,
we're the end of the line as far as like people that wanted to take shit to the
next level.
That's what happened.
They were in Europe and they're like,
this ain't working for me.
I'm going to get out of fucking boat and fly to some unknown land.
Yeah,
so those,
that genetics,
the,
those are the freaks.
Those are the crazy assholes.
You know?
It's like,
I mean,
Australia is a bad ass country.
One of the reasons why it's a bad ass countries.
It started out a God damn prison colony because a logo a lot.
Those people are like the
grandparents and the grandchildren and great,
great,
great grandchildren of fucking crazy criminals from England.
They got rid of it.
Get the fuck out of here.
You crazy as hell.
We're going to send you to an island,
but which is so far away you can never get back to us.
Okay?
We don't want to kill you.
Just get the fuck out of here.
You'll have a skewed accent and everything while they're awesome.
They're really is amazing.
Most well traveled people in the world.
Aussies,
I think because they have to travel to go anywhere,
but it's like everywhere they go.
And they was like,
I'm going to stay.
And you catch Mankin and be here for six weeks.
Yeah.
Oh,
we were in Hawaii and there was a couple from,
uh,
from,
from um,
Australia.
They were from Melbourne,
Melbourne,
and they took the kids out as a long flight.
You know,
they had a fly like 11 hours and then two hours and you know,
it's like,
oh,
fucking just do it man.
Just the friendliest people in the world really are well traveled.
Lanes are amazing,
friendly.
And I think something like 80% of Australia is uninhabited.
Uninhabitable.
Well,
yeah.
It's just put the places that you can't.
Perth,
Sydney,
Melbourne,
like the places you can live are fucking phenomenal.
But I also heard it's the most deadly place on earth.
You can get killed by more insects and indigenous creatures.
They're
jellyfish,
sting rays.
They have a certain jellyfish,
I want to say man of war,
but I think I'm wrong.
I don't think that's the name of it.
There's a,
there's a name for it.
I'm not sure what the jellyfish is,
but a really super toxic one where almost 90% of the people that get hit by this
thing tie.
You got to get treatment like within seconds and they have these giant jugs of
vinegar that they keep in,
um,
like little boxes all around the beach in case people get hit by a jellyfish to
pour this vinegar on them somehow or another.
It's like lessens the impact.
But the f jellyfish are fucking ferocious there.
Toxins are so ruthless,
whatever this jellyfish is just,
it just jacks people.
This one lady was scarred the fuck up.
Is it a box jellyfish?
Yeah,
I think that is,
it was one lady,
her legs.
She made it through,
but her legs were just mangled.
Do you swim in the seat?
Do you get in that way?
That shit son.
I get close to the shore and a boogie board.
If I'm feeling frisky hemp,
would it be to have a jelly fish though?
And when it was black light aquariums in the middle of your living room,
that's like nature's Joe Lava and I get real,
my eyes are very sensitive and when I get saltwater and then it burns like fuck.
I think it's because when I did fear factor a lot,
I had a lot of sunscreen going in my eyes.
It happened many times.
I remember that.
I mean,
yeah,
a bunch of times where I was like on stage and this,
but my sweat from my forehead while being on stage,
the sunscreen would leak into my eyes and it's like I fried my retinas or
something.
Oh,
it's like I,
my eyes are much more sensitive now to salt water.
Yeah.
I think I fucked him up from my boss.
I can't see good.
But I think they're much more sensitive now.
I could tear up real easy.
So I had to wear like goggles and shit like that.
But the,
uh,
the idea that there's some shit out there that can kill you and it does every
now and then every year someone gets bit somewhere and you don't want to get got
by a fish.
Got got a year ago right out here.
Santa Barbara by a jellyfish.
No fucking shark.
Bit them in half.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
Yeah.
And they found a great white really recently around Malibu.
They spot it from a plane.
There's a great white tooling around Malibu,
chief rowdy 10.
Most of these beaches down.
Listen man,
they're out there.
They're there.
They're just a big muscle swimming and fucking Australia.
There's everything.
There's crocodiles.
Crocodiles are easily the scariest fucking thing on the planet for me.
Even more scary than sharks.
Yeah,
because I don't fucking go in the water that much,
man.
So sharks are scary and shit,
but I know they're out there,
so I'm cool.
I'll,
I'll take less chances over here.
You know,
the idea that you jump into their world and it just subject to their rules and
their laws and crocodiles live in our world.
I think like they exist.
You ever see the one picture of the crocodile hunter holding his baby and
feeding of a crocodile,
a chicken that the most irresponsible.
I didn't have children when I first saw that photo.
I didn't have,
it had never reproduced,
right?
So to me it was just a norm.
It was just a logical thing like,
well that's ridiculous.
Why is he doing that?
That's crazy with his kid got hurt.
But when you have children and you think about the idea that just for a goof,
you will stand in front of this fucking unpredictable Munster and take some,
maybe it's one out of a thousand chance you're willing to do that.
What if your kid got eaten by a fucking crocodile right in front of you and
you're the crocodile hunter?
That would make you sound very bad at your job.
What if something happened and it's stumbled as you were giving it the chicken
and the chicken bounced out of it's mouth and it looked at the baby and said,
I'll go for this next.
And it pulls your arms off with the fucking baby and it does.
The role does a death row.
And just snap,
snap,
snap and your elbows fucking pop off and he started shooting like a sprinkler.
You watched it,
you watch the swamp people,
you've seen them out there?
Yeah,
with the to check their traps and stuff and then they just point blank shoot him
in the face with a gun and that's to bring them back in and they're looking for
like 12 footers like me and eat them.
Yeah,
I it's delicious and make nice boots and all that stuff too.
But those guys hunting for them a crazy dude that's a wild monster that you're
out there shooting and alligators are pussies.
They're like poodles compared to pit bulls.
When you compare like an alligator to a crocodile,
crocodiles are way more ferocious,
way crazier,
way meaner,
way more dangerous.
We quicker,
it's just one of those things where you let your mind absorb it.
It's like wow,
that exists among footers man.
How about they don't,
they can hold their breath for like a couple hours.
Just killers.
They can get into like a pond and go underwater.
It just sit there and not move for a couple hours and they look mean as fuck.
They don't look like well-wishers.
They look like they're here to fuck shit up.
He looks meaner than a fucking crack and it looks like teeth are all up and
down.
They look fake.
It's like you sit here and tell kids there's no such thing as monsters.
What if you live in Florida?
Yeah,
there is fucking her in Florida.
And that was under your bed.
What are those deep water fish?
They have like the fangs and the eye and had that thing that uh,
like an intense,
it's almost like,
oh,
I know what you're talking about.
It almost like,
I think it's called the Angler fish.
It has like it's own fake swimming fishing rod.
Sure.
I know what you mean.
Yeah.
And it looks like it looks like a lure in front of them and they fish come near
and he Jackson,
that's he fishes for fish.
That's fucking,
that's how monster son,
lucky,
lucky don't live in his world to an exact two killers of the seat.
And that's like those sharks,
man.
I watched jaws the other night for the 700,000 time because my girlfriend hadn't
seen it great.
And she's like,
she's like,
I don't like these kind of movies.
I was like,
oh great American.
When she get her,
when I hear,
when I hear her shit on movies,
that's how she talks and,
and she,
she,
you know,
she was like,
I don't want to watch it and watch it.
I'm like,
it's not what you think it is.
I go,
it's a movie that plays on your fears.
It's not something that's going to show you a bunch of Gore the whole time
you're going to see Quinn get gut at the end.
But that's it,
right.
It's a glorious thing.
But it's like that whole amazing thing of it playing on your fears.
And so we watched jaws again.
It was this like,
yeah,
dude,
that thing's just a swimming bucking garbage disposal,
looking to destroy.
No reason,
no sympathy,
no empathy,
just muscles and teeth and eating.
And that's fucking bad ass that that exists.
You just stay away from it,
you know?
But she ended up liking the movie.
She's like,
I liked that man.
I was like,
does that tail of the,
see?
How could you not like it?
We have completely separated ourselves from the food chain.
We were just like,
listen,
stop.
No one's eaten us back the fuck up.
Nope.
We're out of the game.
Out of the game.
Here's the deal.
We got tanks.
I got nuclear weapons.
All right.
You want to get crazy?
You want to get crazy will kill you.
All right?
But for right now,
we're out of the game.
So you go eat [inaudible] we're not going to stop any of that.
We're not going to protect the monkeys from the chimps were not protecting
anybody from anybody else.
We let it all go down,
right?
Except people,
except people.
As soon as you start eating people,
you ain't hunting me.
That's for fun.
Some lady got killed in Africa last week,
uh,
ally and made it into her yard and killed her.
She was,
um,
uh,
apparently this is a line had escaped.
There was a hole in one of the fences.
They have game parks where they have lion reserve just wild.
And apparently they're fucking actually fenced in,
which is amazing to try to wrap your head around.
But something like a rhino or a fucking elephant damage the fence and align.
Snuck through.
Started eating people.
Yeah.
And they found her like remains in the bushes.
Just it just nothing left.
What's that?
What's a dollar skin eight or body?
What's the movie with Willem Defoe and the lions and the ghost and the darkness.
Not Willing to,
it's a Michael Douglas and vow kill.
That's right.
Movie is story.
That's the fuck.
Yeah.
Really Happy People.
Osca yeah.
Ooh,
that's a good movie.
That's a great horror movie about a real animal and about shit that can happen.
Fuck yeah.
It can happen.
Dude.
That's an amazing film.
And uh,
really about a,
a group of lines.
I think it was two lions together.
Something.
Yeah.
I think that the,
what was interesting about it was that they didn't know that male lions would a
hunt.
Right.
There was always said that males don't hunt,
they stay home.
But these males just decided to start hunting people cause I got bored.
They're like they let's go hunt.
Hom Yeah,
I think they just realize how easy it is.
Yeah.
I think once one of them just eats a person and goes,
Jesus Christ,
why am I chasing after gazelles?
This is a person as a hundred percent catch.
You ever watch like Gizelle's almost get away.
You're going to have to seven years.
Yeah.
Cause sometimes I take a left when it was a good thing to take a left.
You're gone.
When you watch a tiger chasing down a fucking gazelle or anything online,
in chasing down in any,
any,
anything,
chasing down a fast thing,
but how fucking fast that thing is running to stay alive and then think of how
slow you are.
Oh my God,
we're so slow.
30 or 40 mile an hour.
Chase is happening in the world.
Have you ever seen them attack a hippo?
I saw it was one,
it was like six of them on top of a hippo trying to get this hippo,
hippo,
hippo Hybels,
or like one of the most dangerous animals.
Oh yeah.
And this one,
hippo was just like slowly walking water.
It's like,
like all these tires are lines on it and like just trying to eat it after beast.
A lot of a out of their main videos,
lions attacking hip and it's just a slow walk.
Wow.
This hippo is just being eaten alive.
God,
this is crazy.
I'm watching it right now.
All My god,
this is the lion is riding on the back of the hippo while he's eating it.
Just getting it.
He's just hanging on.
Is that fucking crazy?
And look at,
there's the next day you see it with the,
with the spine is hanging out.
Literally took a hunk out of the,
of the spine of this thing.
Where are you going home and let me get a bite and you ever watched that?
Oh my God,
this is hard to watch.
Mad Cause they can't kill it.
It's
when you see the eyes of what the animal is happening too.
Like why are you doing this to me?
I know.
Who are you eating me?
I just want to go.
He's just dealing with it.
There's a good show called big cats diary.
I think it is a big fan of that show,
but they always have this.
There was one recently,
there was a,
what was it,
a nerd folks
wash as it's called lion attack.
Hippo.
This is fucking gnarly.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
Something completely off subject that is freaking me out.
That video just frequent it.
How amazing is it that that's a real everyday occurrence out there in the world
somewhere?
Oh,
there's a spot of the world where there's a giant monsters taking down 3000
pound animals.
Yeah.
Slowly biting their spine.
You know the day that we're going to get excited where I think we're all going
to call each other and I really feel like the state is going to happen.
Is that breaking news?
It's going to come in and we found big foot.
We got them,
we found them.
We went on.
I think there's,
yeah,
I didn't know.
I don't think it,
I think I'm open to the possibility.
It's just,
you know what?
So your 2011 lots of cameras bring me his head and nothing less.
You know what I mean?
Big Foot is very sexy or that joke he used to have that you used to talk about
in search of a loch ness or whatever it was like it'd be like in search of
snuffaluffagus.
Well now they have the inserts a bigfoot,
right?
Yeah.
And it's like somebody gave money to this and that's one of those things we
talked about,
like we were talking about somebody earlier,
like not believing things are checking fast.
Things are very simple to understand.
Like I've said this before,
like if somebody in this world is levitating,
he'd be the most famous person in the history of time ever.
He would have done the most impressive thing ever.
He would made,
you know,
Da Vinci
and everybody looked like poop,
but a sex professor x from the x men.
Yeah.
It's just like,
what the fuck?
So people would be like,
the others do really could levitate.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's like,
no,
you would be amazing if you could.
You know,
if you really could.
But so the big foot thing,
that logic tells you this,
it's like,
look,
they would preempt the president's state of the Union address to tell you they
found big foot.
They would preempt anything.
It would be the most important story ever.
Yeah,
so a lot of the resources to going to look for it and the only way it can exist
is because here,
here's why.
Here's the side I'll take is we have this arrogance is as men basically that
we've conquered all of the earth.
We know every nook and cranny,
you know there's places that you can go down,
you can go sideways into the earth.
There's just so many nooks and crannies.
Now.
If there's some,
you know,
seven foot eight walking around and hasn't been seen,
maybe in the Himalayas somewhere,
maybe we're man can't get to maybe the abominable,
a bound minimum.
It'll go a little snow man.
Whatever.
The white,
the white,
the white pig foot,
you're more inclined to believe that like the Tibet.
Then the board clients squat bleed,
the Yeti version.
Then the Pacific Northwestern version think it was probably a real animal.
That's what I think.
I think it probably went extinct a long time ago,
which I can't show many.
It's gigantic.
Pethica says the action.
The Chicago Museum,
they have a nice mockup of his,
his skeleton.
Yeah,
and it's like this giant eight foot fucking gorilla and it totally looks like
what you would think of as big foot.
I guess it was by,
it wasn't bipedal though.
It would sometimes walk on a time,
legs,
but enough so that if you saw one walking on its hind legs,
who the fuck knows?
I mean it's all completely speculation of all of her.
If you're playing the the Joe Rogan experience drinking game,
I think that's one shot.
What is the Joe Rogan?
Who's a foster knows I go,
cause I say that all the time.
Who the fuck knows who the fuck knows?
I think that's one shot.
Did you hear that story of Oliver,
the purported man champion ever?
Did I tell you I watched that and watched a whole documentary on him.
He was a chimpanzee.
They just had a really weird,
amazing,
weird anomaly.
A bunch of them walked,
walks straight up,
didn't want to crouch over and walk on all fours and wanted to fuck women
wanting to fuck women.
And it was,
yeah,
was like hanging around with people and really despise chimps.
But he started getting really creepy with the woman and in front of me had a
lock 'em up,
ready to rape all over.
The chimps don't have any moral span.
The Dick gets hard.
They're ready to rape cause that's how it works in the chimp world.
They don't have the in.
So he was doing his best to listen,
but he's fighting against some crazy instincts.
He's not getting any sexual satisfaction and he's going to find it somewhere.
He,
they were showing him because in the 70s they actually concluded that he was
half man,
half eight because DNA testing was so crude that they couldn't narrow it down.
Now they're like,
oh no,
he's just a fucked up.
Hey.
Yeah.
And every once where I think a gorilla came out last year who walks on on,
he was bipedal walks around just looking around at shit just as humans.
It's like w you know,
so many people would conclude.
It's like,
I've never seen that.
It's new.
It's obviously half man.
It's like part of me would like to think there's somebody out there tinkering
with something like that,
but that's a really fucked up thing to do.
Well,
it's,
Leslie happened and there was a recent article in,
um,
I know it's not the best source of the,
the UK in the daily mail was talking about a scientists have created,
I believe it was over a hundred different embryos that were hybrids of,
of babies and you know,
human and some other animal.
Well,
what I recommend created embryos when I read about the light and all the
different shit they did,
I thought it was just Napoleon dynamite fucking around.
We,
I think we talked about the class.
I know laggers.
Israel,
the real deal.
They don't,
I don't think there's ever a time in the wild where they're,
they're in the same habitat,
but you know,
what they said is the only has to happens in captivity.
I think it happens in captivity,
but they were saying this and this has happened recently.
They're like,
they can't reproduce.
So they're all born sterile or they're all,
you know that that's it.
That's one generation hybrid.
It's just like there's hybrid fish that have the same situation.
Some hat reproduce really.
So that's telling you that genetically now they're adapting and this lagger
thing would get killed out in the wild because it's fucking enormous and slow.
It's giant and slow to sitting target.
Like I thought it was really slow.
They're slow because they're,
they're twice the size of a normal lion or tiger.
They're the size of a lion and the tiger put together.
But when an animal is be more scared of it though,
so they might actually be there and art and animals.
Just as you saw that line in Japan on a hippos back,
don't give a fuck.
This is how brilliant Napoleon dynamite was to this day.
It's ridiculous to talk about a lagger.
I just was avoiding talking about this animal.
I was avoiding talking about this.
Cause you know what dude?
The proliant dynamite already covered this.
But you know,
I thought he was joking.
No,
no.
Most people think it's a joke there.
They're so ridiculous looking.
They're cartoonish.
There's the one that you'll see online.
I always look for the video and the one in motion,
it's just this amazingly,
absurdly huge thing.
But it's like,
you know,
they keep miniaturizing things.
I want to see them make things bigger.
Well,
no,
apparently what it is,
is that the,
the gene for like ceasing growth or do the gene that limits growth is removed
when the to mate with each other.
Right.
It's like a male tiger or female line.
I think I got it right when that happens.
The,
the gene for growth,
like the,
the gene for regulating growth gets all fucked up.
So they just grow shoe.
There's one on the other side too.
There's the,
there's the lagger.
But the,
the Thai tie,
I don't know what they're calling.
They're mixing the words together.
So now you're talking about,
um,
you know,
like a tiger with a Maine.
Why not tangled tiger with a main,
oh dude.
What's that called?
Uh,
look up a tea,
Greg maybe or a a tea grass.
Really?
I don't ever,
I don't remember.
It was,
uh,
I,
it's when I was looking at those laggers that time and I started seeing all
these fucked up animals they've been messing with.
It's amazing.
Well,
did they,
I wonder if anybody would like to find out if that happened naturally,
the lagger thing or if that was something that people fucked around with a
assume.
It probably had to.
I always look for videos in motion.
I won't accept a picture.
You know what I mean?
Well,
I don't think Fred scratches the surface.
Joe Rogan.
I understand.
You know what I mean?
It's good when I dig deep,
when I go to Wikipedia,
check your sources and then I check your sources.
Sources.
Has anybody ever been killed by one of these things?
I don't.
I don't think so.
Cause high gone.
This Guy Saigon.
Yeah.
Let me see.
Let me check out a tag on,
cause now and they're kind of,
they're,
they're
funny looking,
but the bangle buyers,
the biggest.
Cool.
These are cool.
It's fun,
aren't they?
Wow.
That's all we need.
More giant shit that can kill us.
There's a photo of this lady lying on a,
uh,
a tie gone and it's enormous.
It's so big.
Oh my God,
it's big.
Wow.
I wouldn't you dude,
I would be scared of a fucking cat that weighs 10 pounds for cat weighs 10
pounds of a rat,
weighed five pounds.
I'm terrified of a rat,
a five pound rant.
This is coming to try to fuck you up.
You know,
it's you just some manage and help God damn help us.
You would feel.
But Tiger decided to Jackie.
Yeah.
They have nothing but bad intentions.
So there's no reasoning with it.
Are they nice to loggers or they're like calm down.
They're pretty docile as a result of being manmade,
sitting around with only zookeepers and zoologists.
And actually no one said it was a jack.
A lagger.
You'd have to be a crypto zoologist to even,
has anyone been killed by Allegra chipped?
Believe I'm doing this.
Maybe there's a or up at Folsom.
I kill folks.
Well,
that's the problem,
man.
This fucking Napoleon dynamite is ruined his life.
People think it's fictional to the point when I tell people,
they're like,
Ooh,
route,
and I'm like,
has anybody Leiger attack kills animal handler first fucking page.
People magazine.
Yep.
Against protocol handler entered lion tigered hybrid space during feeding
oopsies.
Wow.
An animal handler with thousands of hours of experiences died after being mauled
by a 1000 pound lion tiger hybrid.
He was feeding 1000 pounds,
1000 pounds,
half a ton.
You talk,
it says you're talking about an animal.
There's 20 times more powerful than the human being that was feeding it.
One of the most important protocols with these powerful cats in captivity is
never entered their enclosure with the animal present,
especially when it involves food.
Yeah.
She's even like keeping your domestic house.
Cat goes straight for those instincts,
those while instincts.
It's like even if you drag a little mouse in front of it,
they go right into hunting mode.
It's not playtime.
It's like,
oh my God,
that thing's moving.
You've got to kill it.
What an amazing animal that nature has created.
It's basically this super killer that just keeps all the weak things dead and
keeps the population in check and breasts,
breasts and just chills,
rest,
and he would look at the spot.
Look at this spot of the world where the most cattle the most,
you know,
undulate animals,
the most hooved animals are running around those.
That spot spot is Africa,
right?
That's where you get these great her hordes of Willdabeast and Sarah and gather
buffaloes and to make all these amazing fucking animals and that's where the big
monsters live.
They're the cleanup crew man there,
the genetic cleanup crew there to make sure that only the super healthy one
survive.
You make sure you keep your genetic strong because everything is little and weak
and slow.
We're going to get them on the phone and nature
even works in our society.
I think a lot more than than people know too.
It does.
You know?
Unfortunately,
even when it's domestic,
we consider ourselves,
don't you think we weed out the weak shoe,
the mops,
but the mountain keep moving on.
Yeah,
we do.
I think there's a balance.
I think there's a balance in doing that.
I think the week definitely need to be chewed up.
We need to fucking set a standard need to kick people in the balls get him,
well,
there's a lot of weak pitches in this world,
but we also need to have compassionate at the same time.
It needs to be like a,
a protocol.
The need needs to be like a level of compassionate and understanding where you
don't want people to suffer.
You don't want people to starve.
You don't want people who are in bad straits to get,
you know,
people would just got fucked by life and you know,
tornadoes or some horrible thing.
You don't want them to be out in the cold,
but you don't want people being wiki either.
You don't want people being lazy fucks that.
Rely on the government,
take care of their bills,
and then they want to sit around and be a welfare douche.
You know,
there's,
there's that too.
That's real,
you know,
so it,
it becomes a weird fine line.
Like,
where do you draw and how do you,
how do you,
how do you make the distinction between being a humanitarian person and being a
kind person,
being,
you know,
a person wants to help their neighbor and being someone who supports laziness.
Being someone who enables,
enables some broken fuck with no discipline to skate through this life.
That's that,
that,
that whole idea of like Buddhism though,
and his whole theory about it is,
is as you can't end their suffering,
you can just end you feeling sorry for them.
You know what I mean?
You really can,
and not in a bad way.
You know,
you're right.
It's like I feel for him,
but he's not going to affect me in that way.
You can do that with anything.
You can do that with the fucking news man.
Yeah.
You know,
you can decide that the world is ending every day of the week because every day
of the week you can go online and there's some horrible story about some woman
who was killed by her boyfriend and chopped up and put in a fucking meat locker.
There's a hundred of those.
They're coming.
They're coming,
every,
the sky's falling everywhere.
This guy's phone with riots and that crazy guy in,
in,
in Oslo and killed all those kids and like horrible,
horrible,
horrible shit going on somewhere all over the place,
all the time.
But if you decide to take all that in,
man,
and it's certain point,
there's a balance between being informed and it benefiting you psychologically,
there's information and then there's an inundation of information said where now
you don't have a clearinghouse,
you're not processing it,
and now you're starting your leasing out.
Your opinion to,
to those who are giving you all this information and now you're seeking out
particular information.
Yeah.
That adheres to it.
And it's like isolation and lack of challenge of friends and people to say,
no.
Well look at it this way.
I have a buddy who gets real political and thankfully he doesn't live near here,
so I don't talk to him very much,
but he'll just start yelling and getting angry and angry.
I talked to him about like politicians,
you know,
he'll just go fucking crazy.
You see that shit on the Senate floor with fucking Bonner and the bullshit that
he said or a boner.
Is that what the guy's name?
And he'll like argue with you and yelled yo like Yo dude dude dude,
dude,
yeah,
get your own shit together.
Okay,
you're,
you're picking a fight and so you've been digit to this crazy stuff.
You got your whole life investing in it and it's clearly a distraction.
Your own fucked
up light,
which is the theme of what we've been talking about it.
It's like saying like the Buddhist sense,
it's like in suffering and yourself that you won't be a suffering prick anymore
because then you won't care about what other people are doing if you just end it
in yourself.
But then people will say,
well that's ridiculous cause then you saying,
you know,
don't pay attention to politics.
Don't,
which is not what I'm saying at all.
What I'm saying is you got to regulate how you're,
you're,
what,
what impacts you.
You got to regulate what you take in regulate the amount of negativity and
positivity.
You actually can do that and he can have a realistic politics or political,
the politicking.
I'm not mad.
Well it's also in a few like really take it seriously.
You kind of endorse it and if you endorse it even though you know,
like my friend Jamie Kilstein,
he's like super political and he was on the podcast and Brian and I were talking
to him about this and one of the things that we were saying,
we were like,
do you think that even by,
I know that you think it's bullshit and I know you think the special interest
groups and all these things,
different things that are affecting the government and affecting,
but do you think that by like really being into it and critiquing it,
like you almost like legitimize it cause you almost like you almost like say
like,
well this is a real thing that's going on here,
but it's clearly not a real thing.
And not to anyone.
Anyone can get to the position where they can be president.
Right.
Super fucking difficult time.
Every time Ron Palmach makes a run,
even though his message resonates with so many fucking people.
So many people are excited by that guy.
So many people love new radical approach.
Every single,
whether it's NBC,
CBS,
any news coverage,
I'll make him look like a joke.
They,
they are on purpose forcing him to the joke position.
It's like it's so obvious that their news departments are in in some way like
they have a,
an agenda to mock him because there's no cooperation that want that.
Once that motherfucker to be in control,
there's no one who's in a position of power now that would want that crazy
fucking non evolution believing brilliant man who has so many important things
that make sense to say fuck.
They wouldn't let him,
they wouldn't let him.
Then there is no real running for president.
It's fake.
And it's,
we have,
we have to admit that we have to interview you if you have this conversation,
you know like well the Democrats need to do and where the Republicans need to
do.
They're not real.
Your work.
This is a corporation.
Corporations running shit.
And there's a God damn opera going on.
That's what it's like.
It's so antiquated.
This form of,
of communication and,
and this play that's playing back,
which of the Liberals and the Republicans Talk Radio?
It's,
it's shell play.
It almost seems real.
It's one of those things where it's like an insane,
she stepped back and look at all the dynamics of it.
It's like,
you know the Democrats do it,
the Republicans do it.
It's like we get you to not focus on the task at hand.
We'll create,
we'll create.
An enemy will create a fear.
We'll create something and while all of them are running around,
you know enough about politics.
I do too,
but at the end of the day,
whether it's George Bush or Barack Obama,
I ain't going to stop smoking dope.
I ain't going to stop having fun and being curious about shit.
You know what I mean?
It's like they can run their corporation.
Just don't fuck with me and I'm fine.
Well,
that's
how it should be.
But they don't think that the,
you know,
the government doesn't think that they should give people very much freedom
because the more freedom you give more people,
the more freedom you they want.
And the more we keep them.
If you keep them suppressed to a certain point,
but give them a healthy standard,
you know,
not too bad,
not too crazy,
just just keep them down a little bit but not too crazy.
You're way better off in the government's eyes than just giving them free rein
here.
Have legalized prostitution here.
Have drugs decriminalized here.
Make your own choice when it comes to acid and mushrooms and Mescalero,
it's like you said about Ron Paul.
It's like,
you know,
people were surprised.
Obama got elected.
I'm not,
he's of the ILC.
He's a Harvard man.
Best top of his class.
It's all the things we ask of our president.
He was,
they just looked different,
but all the things we asked him and he didn't come and let you know,
like Clinton,
he was kind of a self made guy,
but it's like he belonged there.
You know?
And even if you don't like to hear this,
George W.
Bush came from the ILC.
He wasn't,
you know,
maybe not the intelligence,
but he came from the hill.
You don't know.
Intelligence is a questionable thing.
And this is one.
Have you ever seen some of the videos when he was running for Governor of Texas?
No.
Sure.
But what we do is going to have to enrich.
We spoke occasionally.
You know,
he occasionally when we spoke about certain things,
yeah,
but you got to realize,
first of all,
these guys are working some insane amount of hours a day when George Bush was
campaigning for president and when he became president,
the hours at these fucking guys are accountable a day.
It must be staggering.
The pressure of being the president must be unbelievable.
So of course the guy's tired all the time and occasional let's say something
really stupid cause he's only using fucking half his brain,
half his brains out working right now.
That's why it's like I never questioned.
I just don't look.
I,
I think,
do you ever see the videos of him when he was running for governor?
It would speak Spanish a lot to remember that.
He really,
yeah,
he speaks Spanish pretty fluently.
Uh,
uh,
I thought he took Anne Richards job right from her.
I think so.
It's very beloved.
But she was a democrat.
Very rare.
But she was still like,
I'll pull that the electric chair and I'll put you in it.
But she was kind of bad.
I got an Annie Oakley.
I would love if we had a governor like that.
Yeah.
There was something about that chick.
I mean,
I don't know what her policies where if I would've agreed with everything,
but I'd love the character.
I know it's tough.
Texas,
Texas politics,
but she was pretty bad ass,
but he took her over.
So it's like he was good in the beginning,
man.
Yeah.
You know,
if you listen to him talk,
you know when people say,
oh well,
you know,
he fucking owned part of the,
the,
the Houston was an Astros.
Who the owner.
Yeah,
he only Houston Astros and they all fucking,
it all fell apart.
Like everything he touched fell apart.
Like,
hey,
it's hard out there bro.
Yeah.
It's,
it's hard out there.
Hard out there for an air.
I think that what George Bush provided us with a very,
um,
unique insight into what the being the president is really all about.
George Bush was the first guy where I got to look at the president in office and
go,
okay,
it's clearly they're not letting this guy run this.
Right.
It's as clear as fucking po.
You couldn't make it any more clear.
Every time there would be some shit that would go down.
You would talk about Dick Cheney being in the bunker.
It would be the Dick Cheney is out in the bunker somewhere like Dick Cheney's in
bunker.
Where's Bush Bushes
on the roof?
Uh,
standing in the middle of a red circle and a white circles around it.
They didn't give a fuck about him.
They were worried about protecting Cheney.
It was a,
it's all that gangster politics.
There's that,
that the documentary on right now put Atwater,
who's that campaign at the biggest,
most famous campaign manager ever?
Atwater.
What's his first name?
He's a Republican strategist.
Uh,
he like talk tot Karl Rove,
how to be a gangster.
You know what I really like?
Uh,
he was a real architect of it,
but he was the one hit and it goes back on a scale of one to 10.
How gays call row.
Oh,
he's,
he's 15,
60,
like Marcus Bachmann gang.
He's handjobs behind Kinko's gay at one thing.
You think so you don't think he's got some dude just locked in a basement
somewhere and sucking his dick every Tuesday.
Oh yeah.
He's got some,
he's got some fucking guy that and on my face for a moment.
Yeah.
He's,
he takes care of this guy and some locked apartment with assassin's outside of
every door to they're evil,
evil people.
I was,
this guy just screams forum.
You fucking bitch you to come over here so I can suck your cock and get my
weekly job.
This poor guy just living in a basement waiting for Karl Rove to come over and
fuck his mouth and then leave God.
But those guys,
they know,
they know what to show.
You show him this and then tell him to just show him something.
Brilliant.
Believe.
Yeah,
he's a monster.
That guy is a monster.
You,
you watched the,
the,
the documentaries talking about him and how he fucking figured out how to pull
the strings behind the Bush administration.
He's a master of it all about making a guy like John Kerry look like a pussy for
having volunteered for Vietnam.
They made him look like a pussy.
They're genius and how they dissect hats off the whole Bush administration was
so twisted because they had that guy,
Jeff Gannon,
that prostitute the gay prostitute who was the embedded White House reporter
going after or before.
These guys didn't understand the Internet.
Right.
They didn't get it.
Which is amazing to think that just just in the bushes administration,
they didn't get the internet just of back off.
Well,
there was a guy who he would lie about these softball questions.
You remember?
Absolutely.
We're him.
He would go,
or the story of Mr President,
when are the Democrats just going to come to their senses and realize that they
live in a fantasy land?
Like that was a question to ask and then the real reporters would be like,
who is this motherfucker like,
what's going on here?
They were like looking at this guy,
trying to study them and so then they um,
they started doing an investigation on him and they found out that he had some
gay military escort service where it was like him with dog tags on with a towel
over his cock and he's laying back and this was the embedded White House
reporter and this fucking website was Latin on God's Internet.
Anyone can get on it.
Just www,
horny army Cox or something.
Dot.
Completely Aloof to as a gay escorts or he was a gay escort and he was living
like,
I mean he was an embedded White House reporter.
He's actually in,
stayed overnight once at the White House.
He slept at the White House and the Lincoln Bedroom.
Who's,
who is that call?
Rose boy,
man.
What's going on?
Oh,
there's
somebody,
somebody fucking some deck guy sucking somebody deck.
Okay.
What's going on there?
That whole presidency was so kinky handjobs and a reach around skill floor.
Don't go down that hall.
There's so kinky because it was all suppressive.
Yeah,
it was all,
you know,
they didn't want gay marriage.
They didn't want this.
They didn't want that like that conservative,
but to be so creepy and so suppressive,
most of the people that are really suppressive and creepy like that,
they're afraid of it in themselves or they're finding it in themselves.
So if you look at an administration that was marked by this kind of like creepy,
overly conservative,
overly Christian,
overly invasive sex,
what was going on with that?
What was that?
You know what it was was that they were just fucking,
and they just wanted to keep all the heat off of them.
We need to stop this,
but fucking,
no,
they just can't stop.
But fuck,
I know you don't never know who they're going to find.
They're going to find bloody under Roos and his fucking closet is Joel Olsteen.
Dude,
they're going to want Joe Olsteen,
Joel Ost O'steen,
which was that.
He's like the mega church guy.
Like he,
I say real creepy smile lock,
stock lowered and it has like 18,000 parishioners that is mega church in fucking
Texas and they go out there and think about if they're all paying him just a
buck to be there.
He's doing a nice Improv Gig,
headlining.
No,
they're all paying him a hundred bucks each to be there and he's cleaning up
there.
That's why it's like guys,
it's like rush Limbaugh and you'll see guys,
they're slowly,
Glenn Beck,
perfect example.
He slowly moving its way into the religious sect to the point where in the
religious sec you're protected by the religion.
You can say anything you want in the money.
You don't have to adhere to all that PC bullshit cause fox,
he can't,
if Fox is way too,
you know he,
he needs to let go back.
He wants to go talk about fags and niggers and spics and all the shit he wants
to say.
All the horrible things that even Fox won't let them say.
So now it's like if he's a religious guy,
if he's a religious not he can have his coat,
his followers,
and it's all under the guise of the Lord.
You know as people always do.
Have you,
Lord,
have you been to any Santa clause but you don't even have to pay taxes.
That's the craziest thing about it.
In China for religion,
you don't got to pay taxes.
It's
have you been following the White House Twitter?
Have you?
Yeah,
I've seen this.
Rick rolled somebody the other day.
They resell your retweet about the name at the White House.
Rick Roll someone in the White House.
Rick Rhodes in the White House verified
and then there's the Twitter name,
White House and then they,
they retweeted somebody that said like,
what the fuck and stuff.
I'm like thinking,
wow there.
They're out of control at the White House.
Twitter.
They should not be like,
you know what the fuck on on the White House.
They say WTF.
Yeah.
Somebody,
they retweeted somebody that said,
what the fuck off?
That's pretty dope.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
when you think about it,
man,
look,
there's this guy,
Obama is only like a few years older than I am.
I'm 43,
I think he's 49 or something.
He follows me and yeah,
he follows us.
Oh,
you guys got Obama following?
I'm following.
He's still not,
I don't know what that means.
So I'm on some FBI watch list.
I think we said something about privacy now you layer has way more hits than the
White House does.
Really?
Yeah.
Way More followers.
Buddy from Ohio called me and he was talking about this guy that used to live
with him.
He and this guy was like,
one of those guys would always bring home crazy bitches like the chicks that
are,
you know,
like getting wasted and domestic violence type,
like psycho crazy girls.
Anyways,
he got married and uh,
they went to a wedding and his wife got completely hammered and fucked up and
started hitting him and doing all this crazy shit at somebody else's wedding.
Went into her car and wouldn't like get out of the car.
So they called the cops and the cops came and wouldn't get out of the car and
suddenly like they had to pull her out and she pulls out her boob and starts
squirting breast milk on the cob and now she's like hit with five charges,
including assault on an officer and like,
uh,
Ohio has this law against bodily fluids as a weapon and stuff like that.
So now she's got at least,
yeah.
So now she's got like a fifth degree felony and,
and all that.
Sure.
I have like a squirting flower titty milk from a crippled nipple.
I,
I'm really disappointed.
The Kristina Agular is Twitter numbers.
Why they're only 536,000 oh relationship.
Have you seen her lately?
So she,
I saw her last night on Jay Leno or something.
What happened?
She's big.
She's gotten big.
Listen Bro,
she's not feeling good about life right now.
Big Plumbing.
She's a Amanda.
Slow,
closer,
slow,
kiss her and go down on her and make her feel better and hug her and go to
movies with her and just not getting that right now.
Now I feel a bit lonely.
She needs to get done.
Go real fucking so it gets straight.
Congo wax.
Yeah.
Just give me a call.
Freddy Loc.
Right?
You got so much fucking facial hair going on right now.
You look,
you look to girls,
you must just reek of man.
He's just a furry geese.
You're a furry animal too.
Fucking crazy.
Pharaoh's appeared for the men who can't.
When I see those who can't,
I laugh at yeah,
right now where I'm filming fear factor.
I can't have a beard.
I should shave.
It's the best way.
Don't you think so gay about it?
To have a beard is the easiest way.
Cause if they call you and say we need you with this or that,
you can shave it down.
But yeah,
beer,
it's the natural,
easiest way for me.
Well it's comfortable.
It makes me feel like I'm a man.
I keep it.
I hate my face when it's not.
When I shave it looked like I like now I'm like,
wow,
I like the beard more than I,
my two main real estate between my nose and my lip here,
a conversation.
This is proof that were queer and I was getting,
if I have a boner and tight jeans,
right.
That's what's gay.
Yeah.
Hey,
you guys like boners?
I probably,
what was this thing that you were telling me about that you were reading?
We were in the kitchen.
I said save this for the podcast.
Some mind control fucking book.
Some book about people fucking with your mind,
like your enemies,
like people don't know what to have the enemies.
Where was this is the book the book mind control?
They do.
It's called reading.
Writing.
It's called mind control.
Who Do you know?
Kimmy young.
I believe it is mine.
Control by Kim.
Your line control by Kim Young.
I put it out on Twitter before,
but it's not one of these where it's like,
hey,
here's how you can get the edge.
It's just one of these where it's like,
here's how people see things and you can see it like this way if you want to,
but you don't have to,
but you do have enemies.
Let's call them th the tractors,
let's call them whatever we need to call them.
But you do have people,
like we were talking about people earlier who wish you ill will,
because I'm aloof to that cause I don't wish to the Mll,
I,
I'm not aware of that.
These people can't,
can be out there and you know,
trying to plant things and I don't want to get paranoid about it.
Right.
But they will work to better themselves by solely in your progress.
But all in all you can do is the best weapon is be better than him.
Infinitely knowing that you're better than them and they fucking hate that know,
not even man.
I think the best weapon is she's just to be positive and living well.
Yeah.
And you know what,
every now and then you're going to have to point it out every now and then.
If it gets annoying and he gets in the way,
you're going to have to expose it and people can see that that's a negative
thing.
And it definitely is,
you know,
it's definitely,
no much less energy is,
you know,
is is transferred.
That's negative if you just turn the other cheek and walk away from it.
But at a certain point in time you have a,
an obligation as a human being involved in a community to establish a certain
level of behavior,
you know,
in a friendly level and knowing human nature and knowing the people if allowed
to can get very fucking self centered and be really shitty to each other.
Right.
And the only reason why they're doing it is because no one's checking them.
They either they don't have good friends or they don't have people that are
rational around them.
It just had the balls to step up and and going,
dude,
you're being a cunt.
That simple.
You need peers in life,
social network,
peers and I mean physical ones not on the computer,
I mean physical peers or or that's where your checks and balances come from.
That's why you stopped believing in Santa and shit like that because of your
fucking peers,
you know,
they wise you up or they can bring you down but it can bring you,
do you know if you're hanging around I'll,
I'll bounce if you're negative.
I got no fucking time.
You will,
we go,
we got one go around at this life.
I'm not a religious dude.
So I'm like this is it and I'm going to make the most of it and I'm going to
learn as much as I can do and I will levitate some day and I will find big.
We all agree,
we,
all of us that roll together really have that same sort of sensibility when it
comes to things,
you know?
And I think there's,
there's only one way to go through this life.
You can choose to be happy.
Yeah.
It's a choice to have fun.
I mean,
unless you guys have a serious brain issue that you really need to go to a
doctor for,
you can,
you can choose to it.
You can choose to set your sails in a,
in a positive direction.
And a lot of people just aren't fucking doing that cause they were around some
idiots that are eating up their time.
Right.
And you know,
what happens is most people,
they feel like whether it's after high school or college,
I no longer a student.
I think if you're a student and you keep learning and you keep your mind open,
now you're going to evolve and you're going to remain socially relevant.
Well,
you know,
I it a certain point in time I've,
I've thought that once I started doing standup comedy,
there's going to be a certain point in time where I really felt like a
professional.
You know,
in the beginning I really felt like I was running on ice skates and slipping all
over the place and I didn't have any solid ground and I would fall down and get
back up.
I wasn't convinced I would keep doing it or could keep doing it,
that I would get to a point of,
you know,
of expertise where I felt so comfortable that I could just relax and let go.
Right.
That was always the goal.
There's always the goal where would see a guy like,
you know,
whoever you name your really good comic on television,
you know Jerry Seinfeld,
whoever,
you know Eddie Murphy,
you'd see them on TV,
but like there's no fucking way I'll ever hit that level.
That guy is at this level of perfection where he could never not be funny.
He just in this,
this super powerful groove and I'm like,
man,
what must that feel like to be like totally done?
Like you're as good as you can ever get and you'd never have to worry about
comedy again.
He never get nervous before you go on stage because you're fucking Eddie Murphy,
but then you realize as you get older that that's not real.
It never really happens.
You always don't know what the fuck you're doing.
You always are constantly evolving and working on it and if you don't,
you're going to sock right.
If you,
if you're not always in the hunt and always in the struggle and always writing
and always thinking and always performing,
you're going to eat some dick up there,
dude,
if you're not really,
if you're not constantly improving and then you're going to f so you never feel
comfortable,
you've got to be comfortable and not being comfortable.
Absolutely.
And that's what it,
and it goes for all walks and not even just your career,
but it's like you've got to put yourself out there for everything,
for everything.
That's the only way you evolve.
You know,
my girlfriend,
and sometimes I'm guilty of being too mean to her sometimes because I have a low
threshold for whining and complaining.
I'm just like,
wait,
you're not retarded.
You're not four.
Figure it out.
You know?
And,
and again,
it's called the Penn Pan and absolutely give me some knuckles for that man.
I'm saying
this are rocking it like that.
It's a lot of bitches out there that are quitting racket ball because the wife
wants that extra hour with you.
Yeah.
And it's like,
here's the thing in my whole thing
Hackaball I don't know where that came from.
So what is she doing?
But it's like is she said she's great and she knows this,
but it's like,
you know me,
it's like I,
if you know,
if you're an adult and you're whining or complaining to me,
I'll go off on you.
If you're a kid,
I'll get it.
It's like a kid.
You're,
you're new,
you're learning shit,
dude.
I tell my three year old,
stop whining.
It's just tough.
Dad would never let me whine.
He wouldn't do this.
I go,
this is ridiculous.
You need to keep repeating yourself over and over again.
Yeah.
Be Nice.
It's just like you can get some perspective and love everything,
but my girlfriend is super cool cause she's got to put with a Dick like me.
I'm like the Comic Book Guy of hip hop.
I'm a dick.
You know what I mean?
But you're not a dick.
You're a nice guy.
What you are is you're not tolerant of stupid shit.
I'm not tolerant of stupid shit from intelligent people.
Yes.
Where people will fall back into that mode yet really negative whining mode.
Yeah.
That's not good.
That's what sits unhealthiest fuck.
Yeah.
And anybody does it and she doesn't do that often.
It's just that some people,
when I do,
it's just like I turned into such a Dick.
If somebody fast man,
we have all these different modes.
We,
all of us,
we sort of imitate our environment.
We imitate our atmosphere and we lock into some sort of predetermined pattern
that we continue to follow through our life with little minimal changes here and
there because of horrible fuck ups when you like really get humiliated and then
you'd have to rebuild,
but don't you always see the forest through the trees and don't you always say,
look,
I'm not special.
People get broken up with all the time.
Marriages end all the time.
Deaths happened on timely all the time.
And so people would let one of these situations dictate their entire life.
Like they're the first person that ever happened to.
It's like,
look,
grieve,
feel bad feel for years if you have
to,
but eventually know this too shall fucking pass it.
Always done.
Yeah,
you can.
It's,
you could say that,
but actually intellectualizing that while you're in emotional pain is almost
impossible.
And that's the problem.
The problem is we're,
we're engineered to love each other whenever we're engineered to get things done
by being in tribes and being close to each other.
Yeah.
Being communal and sharing with each other,
like were engineered to love each other's company.
So when someone dumps you,
no matter what,
you could rationalize through the fucking roof.
Oh,
it's going to be fine.
Every,
every dark crowd has a chauffeur lining.
Listen,
you've got to get through the hard times.
You got to the good time to rationalize all you want,
but you're going to howl like a baby when that girl leaves you
swinging that I can get you set up toxoplasmosis that,
but you know what the thing is?
I would cry,
but you know what?
I lived long enough to know that it passes.
Yes,
it does pass,
but you've got to experience it,
man.
You can tell people that all you want and I and I will experience so I don't
shoot away either.
It's like,
you know,
even now,
32 Joe Rogan,
I'll cry if I couldn't move.
It comes down to the guy and I should cry.
I might cry a little girl's movies there.
I believe that.
You know what I mean?
Tangled.
I was watching good will hunting the other than that,
it's not your fault.
You have a tangle isn't even real people.
You guys are too big.
They animated pay.
Hey
cry a little bit,
which was the spectacle.
Pixar movies.
Uh,
Steve Carell.
I wasn't a Pixar movie.
I just think they all are there and there's all those little yellow guys
everywhere.
I didn't know how to deal with that one is what we,
what we've seen before that though.
Um,
I think we were talking about,
oh,
it's not my girlfriend.
I was using her as a poor example,
but it doesn't hurt to tell you how big of a Dick I become.
And she doesn't do it often,
but it's like I become very intolerant of people who it's like you have the
intellect,
you're capable of doing it,
figure it out.
Every answer you need to know is in that computer right there.
Every fucking answer.
You need to know anything.
It's like,
like,
uh,
some friends will ask me,
it's like,
hey,
I can't look my playstation up.
There's a tutorial,
some 12 year old kid on youtube.
We'll show you how to fucking do it.
Everything.
Yeah,
you didn't know is out there.
If you haven't some shitty times in your life,
the best thing to have his good friends.
There's nothing that's even close to it when you're in a shit mood and some you
just,
you just feel like,
God damn man,
my life is just not where I want it to be.
And you go and hang out with like Chili
and Eddie Bravo at Ari and we all get high and go and eat
together or something like that.
You'll be laughing so much by the end of that you'll feel so like if you have
good friends,
good friends can get you through any fucking creepy,
weird shit.
And there's a lot of people out there that don't have good friends.
There's a lot of people out there that really have never sort of fostered any
like really deep connection with people.
Really honest connection with people for years and years and years and years to
the point where you're really,
really,
really know each other.
It's suspicious to me and dude say who comes from his hometown?
It doesn't have any buddies back home or you know,
something like that.
Somebody who can't vouch for his character,
you know,
from way it's like,
are you
speak?
Tell me a few.
I have a few friends.
I have like a four or five friends from back home still I have to retouch with.
Yeah,
but that's it.
There's a,
there was a bunch that I couldn't,
after a certain point in time,
it whittles down.
It's like,
you know some of your friends,
it's like you're,
you're out with him and said,
you got my back.
If shit jumps off going to a wedding bro,
what the fuck is going to check?
What is wrong with you?
Or 30.
So I went out with
my two buddies,
um,
Jimmy did Teleo and Jimmy lawless,
two good friends of mine from back when my high school days,
you know,
there's are my two closest friends back then and I'm still very,
always in contact with them and Jimmy Lawless as a moderator on my message
board.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
he's,
he's a great guy.
And we all went out to dinner last time that UFC was in town.
I got them tickets for the UFC and then we all went out to dinner and we had
some Chinese food when we're eating,
we're sitting around with Jimmy's kids.
Wasn't Jimmy's kid?
It was a,
yeah,
Jimmy lawless,
his kid,
his son was there,
his cousin was there,
and we're all sitting around together.
We're likely look at us,
we're like fucking grownups.
Now how bizarre is is you have kids,
your here's your kid,
your kids,
like a polite young teenager.
But when you say separately from your friends,
you all evolved together.
What do you mean?
Are these the kinds of friends like I,
you know,
I've got friends back home that,
we shared an experience as children but it my life and obviously yours
especially so much different than it used to be.
You know what I mean?
Like a lot of them look at you like you live on the moon or something.
They don't.
They know me pretty well and we hanging out and I guess what I'm saying is like
there's guys,
it's like I moved away and some of them just went a different way and have
different set of beliefs.
Totally understandable.
But there's some,
even though we grew up apart,
evolve together,
like you know,
I have a buddy Scotty Gee who took me to hit the ditch one time in high school,
like my junior year in highs or,
yeah,
my junior year,
his senior year I was,
you know,
I was a jock.
I was into lifting weights and kicking ass.
At least that was,
you know,
what I wanted to be about.
But there was part of me that just was so curious about what these dudes are,
you know,
with the weed getting high.
And Scotty g one time pulls up in his orange bug.
He's like,
hey,
let's ditch and go play pool.
I was like,
all right.
That changed my life.
It made me pretty much half of who I am today that day.
Who wasn't a ditch school.
One day I did school with Scotty.
Gee,
it's because he,
he turned me on that day to cool dope and to seventies rock and roll music all
in one day.
One day Gloria say me and that guy talk like all the time,
like we lost Tux but we got back in touch.
But we talk all the time because even though it was years apart,
we evolve together.
What songs we're playing
the joker I got into Steve Miller,
you know what I mean?
Like that.
The basic pool hall teeth Miller is the most famous guy that no one can
recognize.
Oh yeah,
like see,
like I have no idea who the fuck Steve Miller wouldn't be.
That's not lady Gaga.
He could be at the grocery store.
You'd have no idea.
You're standing next to the guy that sang a million grand.
Fucking probably say his name.
And I still would be like,
all right,
generic.
Now some people call me to space cowboy Tom.
Me The joke.
Yeah,
he's a bad motherfucker.
He had a bunch of jungle love.
That's a great jam.
He had a bunch of great fucking songs and nobody knows what he looks like.
That was him.
That's ridiculous.
Looks like that guy works for Microsoft.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's one of bombers executives.
But there's like guys in your life,
it's like you keep buddies that just kind of turned you onto one thing or two of
you on another and it's like he's,
he was one of those guys and I would have other buddies that you just get along
with,
but,
well,
my tunes part,
there's some can be real weird.
My two buddies,
a Jimmy,
Jimmy,
Jimmy Tutelian,
Jimmy lost.
One of the things that I learned from those guys when I was in high school.
They're both uh,
Jimmy to Taleo.
Yeah,
they're both a year older than me.
One of the things I learned from both of them was work ethic.
These guys Bolt Boston,
their ass,
you know,
there's that east coast work ethic that one of them is Jimmy's a Jimmy Detillie
was an electrician and he had his own company like right at high school.
I started working for works for an electrician for like a year and then branched
out,
got his own business,
had people working for and had fans and shit all over time.
He was always working hard,
never complaints.
He helped me deliver newspapers.
Man.
When my fucking car broke down Boston Globe on a Sunday,
dude,
it was like fucking had a pick him up at like three o'clock in the morning.
I thought,
I didn't think,
I think we stayed up all night.
I think what it is,
we went out,
we went out drinking,
went out to a club and then he came with me and we fucking drove around and toss
newspaper like at four in the morning.
That's when they're hot off the press,
right?
Like yeah,
we're going to do it from four in the morning till like nine and it was like,
I can't believe you'd do this every week.
You fucking idiot.
He was laughing but he's still was down to do it.
Does that,
that east coast work.
I was like,
man,
he's a guy who was already working 50 fucking 60 hours a ride and his own
business.
It can help instill things in use sometimes too.
It's like,
okay,
cool.
I was a lazy cunt,
you know,
and I was not lazy and working out.
Those are the only thing.
I was not lazy,
not lazy,
and going to Taco window class and you get it in my work and sparring and
training,
all that.
There was the only thing my whole life I wasn't lazy at.
But then I went when I would do something that I didn't want to do,
like a job,
I was like,
oh fuck all this.
And for both of those guys,
I realized how hard some people work.
Like Jimmy Lawless went on to be a successful contractor and he got me a job
working one summer with his,
uh,
his boss.
I didn't worry,
I didn't last very long.
I think I lasted,
I think I did two weeks.
We were building a wheelchair ramp for a knights of Columbus Hall.
So for two weeks,
a wheelchair.
All I was doing was carrying cement and pressure,
treated lumber and work,
dude.
So my hands,
you know,
pressure,
treated lumber,
they treat it with chemicals.
So you get these gnarly ass fucking splinters in your hand and were you working
as a labor man?
They're not paying you to buy gloves,
dude.
You just show up,
bitch.
You don't get a glove.
Just pick it up with your fucking hand.
That east coast,
you know,
Boston,
it's fucking freezing out.
Pick that fucking thing up the Hammock,
the bank show up,
show up,
you do your work.
Don't complain.
Yeah.
And so,
you know,
I lasted two weeks,
man.
We were carrying bags of cement all day when he was,
he was actually like a carpenter's apprentice and he wasn't doing as much grunt
work.
Right?
But everybody,
if you want to become a carpenter,
you have to,
you know,
you've got to become an apprentice.
You gotta work hard,
you gotta learn every single aspect of the fucking business.
He realized how much hard work is involved and what does he,
he's huge now.
Like anyone
that said,
you know,
he does really well and you just got to know his own construction company.
And I thought everybody got hit by the economy,
especially in that business because that business is,
you know,
people doing renovations and doing things they didn't want and that's not
necessarily need,
but they might want their elective thing.
Let's build a new house,
let's,
you know,
and so those businesses get hit hard when it comes to,
uh,
you know,
when the economy gets Shitty,
which I don't understand at all.
Yeah.
It's funny cause my buddy a Scottish,
you ended up owning us.
He owns a carpet cleaning business and he builds it up like,
but he showed me that you could be a pothead and driven.
That's what it was.
It was like he smokes dope on the constant like I do.
But like the guy owned a super successful carpet business to the point where you
had to have somebody,
he cleans ice tea and Coco's carpet.
That's hilarious.
They got a spot out in Chandler,
Arizona or something like that.
But it's like,
it's one of those thing coco to hangs around in the house where her ass hanging
out apparently.
So she does all the time.
Oh.
And he just,
well her minions who can clean it for them,
but I think he takes that job himself.
Jesus Christ,
man.
Wow.
That's a big ass.
If you're in the big assets,
that's the ass big thing.
I'm a chick.
That's a big one.
No,
I think it's real big thing.
It's not really their seating white girl with an asset.
Something happened.
Their son,
they did some,
they did some work.
Yo Man,
it's real cause I see it.
Joe Rogan.
Oh the ice tea.
Impressive returns here man.
I heard it said some shitty thing about me.
Really.
Someone was saying that he was happy to go to the fights because he had a CD and
the Joe Rogan run his mouth.
Maybe it was just joking around,
but me as an old school ice tea fan,
I was like,
yeah,
I used to talk too much.
Well I run my mouth,
Yo man,
I ain't gotta hear show broken.
Run his mouth talking expert shit saying thin,
intelligent shit.
And He'd been watching this show at all.
No,
I walked,
I walked in.
I cannot have enough room.
There's not a room on the hard drive for another crazy wacky fucking show.
I saw when I get addicted to us,
it's pretty interesting.
He's got his dog and everything.
I've put that I got a dope pit bull named felony hit and he plays video games to
go out there.
So what you telling me?
I'd like to,
I'd like to be buddies with them.
I hope that works out.
I would love to tell him,
look,
I used to,
I'm sorry.
I know you when I do my commentary.
Can we just hang out?
Is he following you smoke a joint.
See she was following him on too.
Is he following you?
I don't think he doesn't even like next level or the final level kind of video
game guys.
You know the final levels like the baddest boss of the video game,
but I think he should follow you before you him.
I think he needs the yield on that ship.
Jerry's ice tea man.
Next to you.
I've seen you should say I am a man.
I would love to.
I love the guy.
I was a huge ice tea fan when I was delivering newspapers.
I used to listen to fucking colors,
colors,
colors for real.
I listened to a lot of ice tea.
Don't show me regional gangster,
get butt naked in fun.
I used to have all those on cassette son.
I'd be driving around in my fucking,
I had a a Gmc van that I bought for 500 bucks,
Brown with no windows.
What was cargo vans?
And I drove my,
uh,
I've drove that around and deliver newspapers when I was listening to ice tea
called us comments,
syndicate and what was the biohazard years too?
Yeah,
I,
you know,
it's weird to be around the bases now.
He's amazingly relevant.
Isn't that amazing how irrelevant.
He's remained my,
his best work and my opinion is in pimps up hoes down.
Tell everybody that he's a pimp.
You know that he might go back into the pimp game,
right?
It's like I didn't know if he was bullshitting or if he was hustling or,
but I'm like,
if you,
if you talk to ice tea,
iced tea is always talking about and he's a hustler.
So whether or not he ever did any pimping at all is irrelevant.
What's relevant and he talks so much about his pimping that he wind up in a pimp
movie.
That's what pimping is all about.
His pimp hand is strong.
Yeah.
It was like,
the thing is it's like he gives lectures,
like if you've seen his show,
he goes to college.
It's like like Ivy League schools and gives lectures.
I'm like,
that's pretty bad ass and why?
What does he get lunch?
Just on whatever.
I'm like,
oh man.
I would listen.
I would love to get iced tea on the pocket when life gives you lemons to tell it
to suck your Dick.
Joe Rogan is the only thing that I thought it was pretty ridiculous though.
It's when he got mad at Soulja boy for ruling and hip hop.
Did you hear that soldier?
Boy,
he's going to bite I Chet hotmail five minute by minute.
Is that true?
Probably have that much money.
When fear factor gets back on it.
Let's get a jet.
I say,
let's see hammers.
Shit.
No,
I don't think I ever want to chat.
Let's get hell on it.
I'm going to wait for the next thing after the jet.
Yeah.
I feel like as soon as the large Hadron collider kicks in,
we learned some shit.
There'll be some things better than industrial jet packs are available and earth
personal.
I want to find saucer.
It's what I'm saying.
I made out of some titanium type shit.
It doesn't break some gravitational.
You know when a solar backup Holla at your boy.
Then I'll fly through the sky dubs on that shit and then I'll fly through the
sky.
I don't want to be driving around in a model t.
You know what I'm saying?
That's stupid.
I'll wait for the cars to become good to drive.
I want to get myself a mosquito helicopter.
A little person.
I need a little helicopter,
a one seat,
or they sell them since the 70s tiny type of mosquito helicopter.
It looks like a tiny Apache war helicopter.
The fucking dope.
How?
It's like a model helicopter.
You can fly.
You can make one for like a hundred grand.
Do you remember?
Do you remember those army jeeps you could buy and you could put it together?
Like I remember like before I had got my first car,
I was thinking about buying one of those and just like,
Yo,
this is crazy.
Just mosquito helicopters.
Tiny man.
What's the dude flight around man?
They're fucking dope.
I need to be one.
Wow.
How much these costs?
$100,000.
This is pretty bad price,
I think up to a quarter mill.
But I'm talking about like,
think about that.
We could get that you could get to the car,
you know you can land on the roof of a clot from home.
How good must it feel to fly one of those things high as fuck.
Yeah,
Dude.
Let's be honest.
It'd be the shit and those are the baddest man.
You don't want to crash when your highest fucking ruined the cause crushed
because it was hot as fuck.
You got to really know what you're doing before you do that.
It's like I wouldn't ever recommend someone to just started smoking weed to
drive when you're hot.
All right,
you've got gotta be a Goddamn Jed eye night on the weed to just think about
getting in your car and not worrying about it.
I wouldn't have to go all negotiate some crazy maneuvers,
but you gotta be a Goddamn Jedi Knight as a driver already too.
You gotta know your shit as both.
So you know a helicopter pilots have to real sophisticated minds and that cause
you have the road and the rudder and you're basically negotiating two completely
separate things at once.
Yeah.
And these guys can invert and they can go upside down.
It's very complicated and it looks like it looks like a real sensitivity thing.
It is.
And you know who the most bad ass mother fuckers are?
The Vietnam helicopter pilots.
Cause you've gotta be able to fly,
extract men in a in and out and take fire.
Oh she is.
That's why they're all fucking cool and chill.
Vietnam helicopter pilots.
This is an amazing fucking pictures.
Videos.
So let's get one
cause she was incredible.
I know this guy that owns a helicopter,
a company here in Los Angeles and during the Carmageddon he was for $80 he would
like pick you up over here and take you to lax.
The Carmen getting turned out to be nothing turned out to be the traffic was
really light.
Yeah.
Everybody is smart and stayed home.
The real carmageddon is going to be an earthquake when we find out how fucking
trap we really are.
Yeah.
You ever see the movie or a quick breath?
No.
Which one was the access to the most recent?
I think Gerald didn't give me your hand.
It's so bad.
Like the camera's just shaping you.
They're like,
hey earthquake.
And it's like,
I was like,
this is like a 30 minute earthquake.
I mean this is going on for a long fucking time.
Earthquake last about two minutes.
I was like,
Jesus.
I think the one in Japan lasted a long time ago.
That was like forever.
It was just a,
I think that might've been like 30 minutes and be like,
let me off this mother fucker.
I would have liked to find out how many minutes that is.
Eh,
I don't know if it was 30 minutes,
but it was on and off for four hours,
wasn't it like a
oh the aftershocks and she shot the aftershocks are ruthless man.
You know,
aftershocks can be like an eight when you have a an earthquake,
that's a nine you know,
8.9 magnitude.
You know the aftershocks wood must be incredible.
Yeah,
I was living in,
sorry,
when I was living in Hollywood in [inaudible] 95 I got it.
I didn't,
wasn't here for the 94 earthquake,
but I was here right afterwards or was,
it wasn't the north.
Now he's at 94 [inaudible] 94 I went the route here literally two months later,
parts of the highway.
We're still fucking falling over and I wasn't here for the big one,
but I was here for a 5.5 5.5 to 5.7 something like that.
I was sitting in my apartment and all of a sudden the walls of the apartment and
a sway back and forth,
like I was in a refrigerator box and the crazy,
it didn't even seem real bad.
You feel about that big.
Yeah.
I felt like I was hallucinating.
We'll all just started moving.
It wasn't even a noise.
And then you hear some dog,
dog,
dog.
Yeah.
Just crazy.
Thump,
thump,
thump.
So like you could hear the earth literally moving and making noise.
Like rock SLAAC a sliding next to each other.
Yeah.
That's fucking,
don't you feel like,
like I felt,
I felt when I'm like,
why?
I remember so well it was Monday,
September 10th,
2001 there was an earthquake.
It's about 4.5 wow.
And it shook me up and I was reeling from trimet and obviously the next day
something bigger happen.
Right.
And I mean maybe it was like that weekend or something,
but I remember it was my first like,
you know,
moderate earthquake.
Now I won't up unless it's like,
you
know,
Shit's really moving.
But I was in an apartment to time.
It was swaying and then it was eerily quiet and then all of a sudden,
yeah you heard that shifting and shit.
But I felt so helpless.
I was like,
there's nobody you could call.
This is one big bad beats.
There's nobody who could kick this earthquakes ass.
And you feel about that small cause you realize man and you think God,
you don't live in some third world where we're all made a dirt.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Cause it's like we have pretty good infrastructure here and it's still will go
down.
Well we have to accept the fact that the,
the,
the top,
the top of topographical surface of the earth,
the surface of the earth changes.
It changes the topography constantly.
You know,
we know that,
you know,
there's like fish bones and shift that you can find in Montana through tectonics
or only fine because everything moves.
Everything is constantly moving.
You know,
they know that mega dawn's,
they found mega don teeth in Montana.
So Montana at one point in time was like under the ocean.
We know that this whole thing used to be pangea.
It used to be one giant continent and something happened.
Or supposedly that's the most widely accepted theory until someone comes up with
a better one.
Well,
I mean you put all of those countries together,
they,
they fit.
Yeah.
And Shit.
Shit changes and moves man.
And we just got to accept that.
And sometimes the spot you're at sucks now,
you know,
it changes,
the Bering strait things come along and steal things up or we fucked up like
Japan,
human beings fucked up and created some spot where you can't hang out anymore.
You know,
we're going to put a fence up around this and you know,
put some big skull and crossbones.
Shit,
don't go near.
We broke one of the spots.
Yeah,
we fucked it up.
We broke up for good Kermit.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's the,
the earth is constantly gonna Shift.
There's no,
we know that for a fact that the North Pole is moving towards Russia at some
sort of a,
a crazy pace of like 35 miles a year to the point where the pole is shifting and
they apparently had to,
they had to reroute some planes in Florida.
They had to do something to the runway to adjust for the fact that it's moving.
The poll is moving in a certain direction.
You could see it visually like it within even a hundred years.
That's scary.
It's crazy.
You know what I mean?
Apparently though,
that's inevitable.
That's just how it always goes.
We're confused into thinking that the state that this country is in right now is
the state that it stays in forever.
That's what we did.
We plant our flag here and nothing will change,
but it's like in Venice,
Italy,
all of it.
They're going on there and there's nothing they can do in Venice.
What happened with Venice here in California,
they tried it.
It just didn't work out,
but it's like eventually earth is constantly changing you.
Dennis is going to be gone in a hundred years gone.
That's what I mean is completely submerged.
Yeah.
Well the,
unless they can come up with some engineering,
but you're really fighting things off like in New Orleans.
Well,
you are,
but that's,
that's still a possibility.
You know,
I don't,
I don't think that's the right way to do it,
but try to convince everybody to get out of there,
you know?
And then everybody wants to go,
oh,
but the history,
no,
that's cool.
You know,
there's some awesome real estate.
It's called Atlanta.
It's off the coast of Spain.
You fucking know go out there too.
They didn't want to abandon that shit either.
They loved it.
It was the best civilization ever,
you know,
and it,
things change,
things shift.
You've got to keep moving.
You know what an idea I heard recently that I kind of,
I thought it was the most credible one about,
um,
how did Easter island,
but the,
the,
the um,
what do you call it?
The Stonehenge through wintertime on ice.
Ever hear of that one winter time?
Would they moved them on ice?
I just did it on ice.
You ever heard of that thing?
I guess that would work if you had enough ice so they could ice up there.
Cause I think the weather is that it feels like you would have to have like a,
you would have to like really lay it down nice and thick and then even then what
support that kind of weight.
But they were saying like the idea that there was no tracks,
there was no evidence of it.
But it's like,
you know,
when you don't have TV,
your mind can come up with creative shit to move things.
It's like I don't,
what do you do you think they were put there by aliens?
I don't know man.
Put them there and it's just too,
we had the guy from ancient aliens on the last podcast,
the last episode.
I got to listen to that one.
I didn't listen a lot of interesting one.
Um,
you know,
he's,
uh,
he's really a big proponent of what's called the,
um,
the ancient alien or a alien astronaut theory that,
you know,
earth who was seated or at least,
we were given some information or some,
some technology at one point in the past by aliens.
And he's 100% convinced.
I'm not 100% convinced,
but I think it's a fascinating topic.
You know,
it's,
it's a very sexy,
just like big foot and it's very sexy.
It's a,
it's a,
it's an interesting topic,
you know,
I think,
uh,
it's certainly possible,
you know,
I mean,
look,
if we know that if we can send something to Mars,
even if there's not a person in it,
just extrapolate the fact that as technology grows at an exponential rate,
ego,
a thousand years from now,
just this society will be able to do something crazy like visit some other
planet.
So we know that it's within the grasp of potential.
It's within the grasp of reality.
I just feel like the way we are,
and with the Internet and everything now,
I think we're do something monumental in our lifetime.
And I mean monumental like,
you know,
I use a big foot thing as an example or a loch ness,
whatever it is,
just something really amazingly monumental that will galvanize the world to at
least for a day or two and go,
holy fucking shit.
You know what I mean?
We have this weird desire to uncover hidden secrets.
You know,
people love.
That's why we love mysteries,
man.
You know,
I got sucked into watching uh,
one of those 48 hour mystery shows,
you know,
those real live shows last night.
Wow.
There's a good one too,
man.
They got me,
it was a preacher that killed his wife and the wife and the mother of his
children because he was having an affair with his younger holler.
Cheddar's newsmagazine the,
yeah.
When the guy,
he always says that he's got a great voice hour special on a man.
I watched the shit out of that show.
It was creepy as fuck this dude grow.
I mean,
man,
he was such an idiot.
Like he left his tracks everywhere.
I mean,
he did everything wrong.
This guy,
I mean from,
from talking to nine one one,
I mean,
he was talking to downland one and supposedly putting clothes on her while he
was talking to her.
She's dead weight,
completely unconscious.
And he supposedly has the phone up to his ear and he's like,
like he didn't even think it through at all.
Folks just can't be,
he's a fucking idiot.
But he,
uh,
was banging this hottie she was pretty hot though.
She's kind of Chubby,
but hot as fuck.
She's really pretty.
And He,
uh,
he killed her for her and he even told her,
he told her he killed her to be with her and then she left him and he was like,
you know,
hey man,
I fucking killed my wife to be with you and you leave me,
you know?
And then she was like,
oh my God,
he's going to kill me too.
So then she started talking to the cops,
but before then,
apparently she was,
you know,
she was trying to tell the cops,
nope,
never fucked them.
We're not having an affair.
She denied the affair and then,
you know,
he threatened her that she would,
he would kill her if she told anybody.
And she really,
she goes and testifies on the witness stand,
but it's so crazy,
man.
The emotions,
the real raw emotions of seeing,
uh,
that woman who he,
you know,
was living with those that he said he loved her.
They were,
fuck they're having sex.
And she's on the witness stand telling everyone that he killed his wife and that
he explained how he did it,
how he smothered her with a pillow and how she was gasping for air.
And then he thought she was already dead from the pills,
but she started gasping for air.
So then he smothered her mouth with a pillow I get is some dark,
dark,
dark shit.
And all the while they're looking over at the,
the,
you know,
focused in on the,
the preacher and his eyes are shifting back and forth and left and right.
You're like,
oh,
this is so
creepy.
Dark.
Why don't you just break up with her,
you fuck head while the wife of his,
the mother of his children to the,
it's two cute little girls.
You kind of wonder where somebody is.
Mine is when it's like,
oh,
I'll murder them.
That's what I'll do there.
They're figuring,
look,
they're bullshitting people all day long with this religion,
with this nonsense.
They're not living,
they're not living this way at all.
They're not real Christian.
So many of them,
they get a taste of that power and the girls are smiling and next thing you know
they're getting their dick sucked in the back.
Well,
it's like they,
it works as a perfect disguise for them because not only,
you're not going to suspect them,
they're going to be able to get away with anything they want to all day until
it's like,
but you know what?
Irony always tells you it's like a guy that that's that against gay people get
married to the guy getting dry hand jobs on the side from little boy,
but fucking dudes.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Back in pooped,
it's exactly what it is,
man.
They're trying to throw you off course.
The trying to let you know,
I'm on your side.
You're just God damn queries.
What are they doing it all?
I've never done anything to anybody to hurt anybody and apparently they're
staying married a lot more than heterosexuals are keeping it together.
That's queers and we got there.
Brian,
what are you holding up?
This is a video on youtube.
It's gotten like almost 6 million hits.
I this guy built Stonehenge by himself.
His own version of it.
Using only like ropes and would straight poolies lippers.
Yeah,
it's on Youtube.
It's called building stone head and shit.
The man who can move anything.
Oh Wow.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah.
I mean
the idea of that,
people always say that it's impossible for people to move those today.
I always go,
man,
how can you say impossible?
Yeah.
That can't say impossible because levers and fulcrums are fucking amazing.
They allow men to move massive thing.
There's a video,
a photo online.
I guess there's video of it to have this gigantic earth crushing machine if they
haven't in Russia.
It's like it digs tunnels and it's so goddamn big stress.
I wouldn't even know this thing exists like a thousand feet a day.
It tear down or something like that.
If it wasn't for the Internet,
I would never know this existed.
I would think this is just like some fucking like a a fake machine and a John
Carpenter movie about space.
You know what I mean?
But meanwhile it is real and these things can just do insane things to move
earth and you stop and think about it,
man,
look,
human beings are capable of ingenious feats and whether it's building some giant
machine to move things or figuring out some crazy series of levers and,
and,
and wedges and dedicating all this time to doing it.
It's,
it's very possible that they had some in insane like technological capabilities
that we don't credit them for because it's just too many thousands of years ago
and we don't,
we don't know what there,
during the fire at the library of Alexandria,
we lost everything.
We lost all their written work.
Right.
Their history and you know,
so there's a lot of it.
They're trying to piece together what the Egyptians couldn't,
couldn't do well they,
they,
you know,
and I've seen a lot of the ideas of how they got each of the things together.
But what surprises me is that the GMS,
that geometric and the,
all the accuracy behind it,
that's amazing.
That's what's the,
it's not the lifting that impresses me.
It's the geometry to the point.
More so than any,
any other manmade device can,
can pinpoint things in the world.
It's like,
you know,
the,
they did it amazing.
They did it so that it's very close to pointing at perfect north,
south,
east and west.
And they reconciled the,
the lack of perfection with the procession of the equinoxes every 26,000 years,
there's a cycle and the earth wobbles on its axis,
so it changes the night sky changes.
So it's the way it points to certain constellations and stuff is off or on,
depending on the procession of the equinoxes,
you know?
So it's,
it's,
there's,
it's amazing what they did mathematically,
but it's,
it seems to be that it can be done.
Yeah.
I mean be done with,
with,
with the animals and,
and,
and slave labor for the love of God.
They say though that they don't believe it was slave labor.
Now they believe that they were paid well and that they were a w considered
working craftsmen.
Maybe it was like during the great depression when they erected the empire state
building and,
and,
and the uh,
the um,
the Chrysler building.
It's like,
okay,
let's provide jobs and these are great jobs for guys in need of work.
So it makes sense,
right?
All come one,
come all,
we're building this fucking amazing thing.
But I think they respected people's ability to construct them.
I think one of the reasons for this conclusion is that they found some sites,
home sites of the workers and the food that they had,
like the,
the bones and stuff was like,
you know,
high end food and that the,
the clothing was like fairly high end.
And so that what they were looking at was like saying like,
well these people aren't slaves eating slop because people seem to be getting
good food and good clothing and go out there.
Probably not.
Well,
I think they found bones and certain things that indicated that they were,
you know,
eating expensive stuff.
So I was like,
oh,
they're,
they're paid workers.
These guys are interesting.
They're a rather,
um,
you know,
a skilled workers rather than just thinking of him.
A slave possibly brought from all over the world.
If you're thinking about that,
because that was a big hub of trade back then too,
wasn't it?
I
would,
I,
if I would be willing to just,
how much would you be willing to pay just to go back in time just for,
let me watch them build it for 20 minutes.
Just let me watch them.
Oh,
dog.
Tara.
Dactyl that's the thing.
It's like,
just because people,
this is the arrogance people have in modern times.
It's like,
look,
you know,
we knew flat screen TVs were common in the 70s we just didn't have the fucking
technology,
but we wanted him really bad.
So that's kind of the same mentality.
They have be like,
look,
we don't have cranes so we've got to make something in the meanwhile,
God,
I would love to have seen it though.
I believe that.
I believe.
I don't,
you know,
I at one point in time subscribe to the alien theory,
but I did it with very little consideration.
I did it because it was like fucking aliens made that I didn't like sit down and
really work it through.
I just fun to say we're fucking smart.
Well it's,
it's that we're smart,
but it's also that we forget shit sometimes and then the people learn some
pretty,
pretty deep and impressive stuff.
And then,
you know,
the small group of people that we're concentrating on that died off and other
people didn't take up the discipline and you know,
we lose,
lose touch with things.
Right.
It's just amazing to think that they lost touch with a city.
Like the entire structure was completely abandoned when people found it because
you know,
the Sphinx was covered in sand.
You know,
like even when the Polian found the spanx,
it was covered to its neck and saying that was the place was abandoned.
But it's amazing how like basically like you're saying,
ignorance can sweep the world to the point where they stopped using that psychic
guy that that,
but how bizarre is it that you can actually abandoned a whole area and then an
area that was literally the peak of civilization.
At one point everybody moved out and then moved into far inferior shit holes
that were right down the street like,
and then they set up shacks and start grilling shitty houses.
Who knows?
Man,
who knows?
I mean there was a bunch of things that happened was political unrest.
They were conquered by the New Orleans.
A lot of things happen to ancient Egypt.
The fact that they kept it together as long as they did all those pharaoh's one
after the other.
They're all building pyramids.
All building giant fucking Mani.
The Holy Roman Empire comes together on the other side too.
And it's like you're talking epic wars with animals and shit that you can't even
begin to imagine.
Must've been amazing back then.
What a fascinating traveling all over,
bring in spices and shit to trade with bringing dope son.
I got the funny though.
If you had to go back and live in that world,
you would fucking hate it.
You wouldn't want to kill yourself.
You wouldn't even want to live.
But back then they didn't know any better and they just kept on trucking,
man.
I just did it and it's like that's like the people who set out to discover
America.
It's like this sucks.
Let's go see what's over there and if and if it's socks so that we're fucked,
but we'll stay.
God Damn.
And we're going to have to probably do that sometime to some shit's going to go
down.
Some tsunami going to hit the west coast,
Peel Malibu out into the middle of the ocean.
Just giant fucking Johnny Carson's size of states floating out in the middle of
the ocean.
But that squad will be up there like red dawn in the mountains.
Dude,
we'll be out.
We'll be up there with fucking canned food and be stuck in Burbank.
Yeah,
I'll be stuck.
Browbeating of Hormel out of the hot.
It'll be hiking is way over here.
Yeah,
I'll bring fishing poles.
So we're going to go fishing for sure.
Fuck yeah.
We're going to go to lake state and catch some large mouth bath son.
Let's do perhaps we'll use rubber worms.
We don't give a fuck to your hands.
Do you ever see that shit where they just grabbed their hands and fish cafes?
They call it noodling.
For some reason I can't get with that.
That sounds like the south.
The South is one of the least appreciated,
uh,
forms of entertainment.
Hell,
this shit.
And the people would do it in the south and the efficient for these,
if you don't know what noodling is,
they catch giant ass catfish like a hundred pounds.
I'm a monster office down the hall.
They stick their hand inside the cap fits his mouth and they Gillam they grab
them and they pull them out.
Yeah,
that's insane,
man.
You're letting that giant ass fucking fish bite your arm and you're trying to
kill it with your bare hands.
They literally have like a life or death,
mortal combat battle with a giant fish in the water.
The one of probably other than a sturgeon,
a couple of other fish,
one of the biggest freshwater fishes there.
They get up to 47 pounds.
What the biggest bass was what?
22 and a half pounds.
Large mouth,
I think it was like,
yeah,
other than a sea bass or something like that.
You're talking cat fish get to be the size of of medium sized dogs.
They get even bigger than that man ain't China.
You ever seen some of the ones that haven't I in Thailand and Vietnam,
their GI,
they're like,
they're basically like sea monsters.
Lionfish.
They probably,
you know,
responsible for a lot of like depictions of sea monsters from ancient tradition.
Oh yeah.
Fucking little dogs and shit.
Early babies.
That's,
that's all.
I got a baby floating around the water.
A fucking hundred and 50 pound catfish comes along.
I'll just eat your baby.
I'm like,
you don't think,
you don't think a baby's been eaten by Cath or sometime in the history of that
shit.
It probably has.
I mean want to see it.
That would make me feel bad.
Yeah.
So let's go.
I want to go,
let's [inaudible] are you in town a while or we're going to go?
Yeah.
Well I'm filled with fear factor right now.
Back to work.
How is it?
How's it going?
Very strange.
It feels bizarre.
I can watch.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
And I want to talk to him and watch it.
It feels like,
uh,
like,
like our Matt Kuehn.
It's one of the producers said it best.
She said,
it feels like we all went into a coma and woke up and just started doing fear
factor.
How many times in history has this ever happened where they took a hit show and
brought it back and it's a hit show of family.
We don't know if it's a hit show.
It can be a total flop now.
And you guys are going to be syndicated the globe over,
you know that she knows most of your staff return almost everyone.
Well,
the beauty of fear factor is that the people behind the scenes are the nicest
fucking people in the world.
Everyone is so nice and Rupert the director,
so great guy and he has all these cameramen who follow him wherever he goes
because he's a great guy to work for.
Super Supportive,
Super Nice,
just to an end,
very competent,
an excellent director for those kind of like action reality shows and he's a
genius for that Shit.
And so he has this grand crew and then Matt Kunis does the nicest guy ever.
He's one of the executive producers and he brings his crew and David Horowitz is
another one on the nicest fucking people I've ever met and he brings his crew.
So it's like this giant group of really nice people and almost 80% of them are
still working for the same guys.
Oh,
that's all they brought everybody back together again.
The same sound guys while the same camera guys.
I mean it seems bizarre as fuck and that's how people get shit done there.
That's especially in this town.
Like I was saying,
they don't do that.
They don't just bring a show back.
So weird like the first day and I'm like,
you know,
stare fear in the eye and you're wearing on your way to winning $100,000 while
I'm saying it and they're cheering,
I'm going,
Whoa,
this doesn't even seem real.
All the sudden the helicopters are flying overhead and people are fucking dive
it off these helicopters and it's fucking crazy.
This man,
the other one is still globally syndicated.
Right?
It's still,
that's,
that's what happened.
What happened was fear factor was on this thing called chiller.
Chiller is one of NBCS little satellite networks,
a small network that they have and they played the replays on chiller all the
time.
They got killer ratings like way better than any of the other shows on chillers.
So what,
what are we going to do?
You know,
what's,
uh,
you know,
what's,
they didn't never expected it was going to like even other and other NBC,
um,
little,
the other affiliates which fighting to get the fear factor reruns on their
network.
Oh Wow.
Because it does so good on chiller.
So then someone,
uh,
I guess Matt Kunis goes to NBC and says,
listen,
let's fucking bring this pitch back.
Come on son.
You know what it was is because the,
back when you guys were on the air before it was before the shit was real viral
on the Internet and you thrived.
But think about now with the Internet,
cause that kind of is all great for just good scenes.
Yeah,
good,
good.
Like,
you know,
like any,
any crazy stunt and he crazy wild shit that goes down.
Yeah,
that's definitely going to be good fodder for the Internet.
But it's also that reality shows we're sort of the redheaded stepchild of
television back then.
There's so many of them now,
so many different games shows and I think fear factor and really survivor first
sort of pave the way for this sort of kind of a crazy extreme game show on
television survivor of course,
being much more about,
you know,
the people and getting to know them and them living together forever.
We're working together.
And then the,
the fucking psychological aspect of voting each other off and all that shit.
Any of the stunts.
Just insane.
Oh dude,
there's so nuts.
I wish I could fucking tell you though.
There's,
some of them are so ridiculous that they had this tell me donkeys.
Semen.
They had to tell me and I w y.
Oh,
ah.
I've just made that up.
They had to tell me,
um,
they had to tell me the things twice because I was like,
what are you talking about?
You tell me this again.
They're going to do what?
Ridiculous.
Wait.
Are you guys going to top yourself?
I saw people is in eighth grade.
When I did it used to watch for your factor.
I'd watch like this all the time.
I just,
for some reason I thought I smelled like I would,
my gag would hit if I,
I thought it smelled what they're thinking about the HD.
If they're going deep well that's one of the things they thought about it.
They've got like a hundred fucking cameras on everything now.
Yeah.
They're going to get every angle,
no bugs bursting and writing I the one episode where you almost beat the dude
up.
That was pretty funny because he hits of our sheet.
He came up and hit somebody whose wife did is somebody that was very sad,
but it's funny to watch the little dog [inaudible].
Well,
when I grabbed him,
yeah,
he rolled over.
I just got hit me,
man.
Yeah,
well it looked like he thought he thought he was going to two and then he
realized how Adeline he was.
Well,
when
someone grabs you a Thai clinch,
if you don't know what the feeling is like to get caught in what's called the
plum and then with the Moitai plumbing,
he grabbed the back of someone's neck.
You can control the fuck out of someone with that position anywhere.
That's my Goto Shit.
If I think of guys trying to hit me,
I just grabbed the back of us.
I mean it's not,
I shouldn't say my code to share cause it's never really happened before,
but automatically in that spot and no one ever on the show I'd ever gotten in my
face or screaming in my face before like,
and this guy,
we'd been told before that he was dangerous through his wife,
down on television and assaulted and got on another show.
So I was like this guys,
I'm not going to let this dude hit me,
but you Greg,
that's the best way to control somebody,
man.
Grab a hold their neck like theories that kid.
Do you remember years ago there were beaten his wife,
there was some special ops guy who was trying to sniff,
sniff you out one night.
Like you're at the comedy store.
I had a special special ops like army rangers sent me.
He's a big dude.
He's about six foot five.
And you could tell like he was trying to challenge you a little bit.
Like you were told that that's friends with um,
what's his film?
Mike or Somebody who's friends with nick?
Yusuf.
Was He friends with talk?
It was really mean to Brian.
That's a big ass.
And then he was trying to sniff around you for a second,
but then like you did this thing like where you stare at them and they liked,
there was a stare off at like two dudes sniffing each other.
I was like,
oh this.
And then all of a sudden like,
he almost like,
it's like you sent out some mental message.
He's like,
I got it.
But it just stood down.
It was like I got,
I understand he was drunk and I was trying to tell him that he was drunk and I
was trying to tell him,
uh,
you know,
there's no need for me,
you to be aggressive to me.
I'm not doing anything to you.
Right.
And then,
you know,
he was talking about them and see a thing.
He was giving me a hard time because it was the night of Mitzia,
you know,
and he was saying that he grew up in Boston.
We don't play that way.
If you want to kick somebody,
if you fucking don't like somebody,
you don't,
you don't just talk about it on stage.
You kicked a fucking ass.
And I go,
really?
I go,
you're not allowed to work things out.
You can't work.
You can't talk.
You have to beat each other up.
He said,
yeah,
I go,
did anybody who thinks like that?
For sure.
You haven't been in a lot of fights,
right?
Like you haven't been in a lot of fights.
You don't know how to fight.
And then he got angry at me.
He's a good food.
The fuck do you think you already told me?
I don't know if I,
I go,
if you knew how to fight,
if had been in a lot of fights,
you'd know that you get hurt in fights.
You break your hands and shit.
Punching people are weakened.
Yeah.
And you go to jail,
you get,
you get arrested.
You know,
I go,
it ain't that easy dude.
It's,
it's illegal.
And by the way,
you kick someone's ass.
They don't like that.
So what do they do?
They come back with a bat or they shoot you when you're not looking and cut your
tires every day for the rest of your life.
You know,
people don't just like getting their ass kicked,
man.
And you're living in some crazy boondock saints,
fake world.
We just get away with shit and move on to the next scene.
Exactly.
You know,
and so I said that to him.
I was like,
you just to fucking chill out man.
Leave me alone.
I'm not fucking with you.
Don't fuck with me.
And then he,
he backed away but then he came again and then he keep Brian a hard time.
It's like intimidating again,
but it's like that second time he came again like you like gave him this look
like that look you get when two dudes are about to throw down and even in the
way off,
you know like that.
Yeah.
Like you gave him this look that like,
it was almost like Michael j,
Fox and teen wolf and he was like a keg of beer and his red,
his eyes turned red.
I was like,
well,
cause the guy picked up on it was like,
oh,
I get it.
Well here's his drunk and stupid and foolish and poured Nick Usif.
You know,
it was a good dude.
Good Buddy got around them.
But any of those.
I'm
from Boston guys.
You know I'm from Chicago.
We don't fucking play that way.
That's just come from everywhere.
But whatever dickless thing to say.
Higher Standard.
You're threatening me with your geographic location of bad asses from De Moines.
I don't care what the fuck a lot of them,
by the way.
Wrestling Shit to do out there.
Pick each other up and throw each other on their heads.
Bad Ass motherfucker.
The last thing you want to do is wrestle some dude who lives in the middle of
nowhere.
Yeah.
That's why the Iowa Hawkeyes especially if they have brothers like those Matt
Hughes type characters.
You don't want a dude with a brother who lives in the middle of nowhere where
they're both athletically like superior DNA and they're beating the shit out of
each other all day and your dad's scheduling fights to fight your brother Jesus.
Well,
you boys need to work it out to Europe together.
We're going out on your own movie with Stephen.
See that movie with Stephen Dorff where he goes to prison for shooting a guy or
something like that who broke into his house like it shows how he has to adapt
to the prison lifestyle because they make you fight.
Come on Stephen Dorff fights in prison.
He gets beat up the DVD type shit.
Nah,
home boy.
This was a,
this was a hit movie.
Come on sign.
And do I ever come incorrect with movies?
What happened to Cuba Gooding jr he should have never happened.
That's what happens is some,
some dude's just disappear,
man.
I was Stephen Dorff.
I would say that's one of 'em too.
He was,
he was in Goddamn blade.
Um,
he's still around.
He's still around.
He's about to race that new movie with Christina Ricci.
Oh,
he is?
He's got a bit of an accent it up before in the bathroom and Jeremy Hood,
who's bigger time?
I would like to sit down and watch that.
Oh yeah.
I'd be like,
well,
he's kinda point man.
That's got to put no,
no,
he's,
he's right too.
Yeah,
you would because you'd be like,
you'd like to see them both kicked the shit out of you to help.
Max Kellerman sits down on HBO and he has two boxers sit down next to each other
and he interviews them and he has,
I'm talking face each other about what they're going to do.
I would like to do that with him.
That'd be fun there.
Take me,
take me to fear factor.
I take me to UFC again or you have UFC match.
Mashable.
You anytime,
dude.
Anytime.
Because I want to get into that gets people.
All My,
a lot of my listeners are now asking me why don't want to ever talk about it.
It's like I said earlier,
I won't talk about something.
I can't talk about it intelligently and it's like I'm just now new to it.
I could talk about boxing and tell it.
Eat up a lot of your time,
man.
There's a lot of fights to watch.
I'll watch the kids to learn.
It's like I,
you know,
I know fade or million echo is,
you know that guy we,
that's right.
Dan Henderson knocked him out last night.
I was hearing about this then I saw what you were tweeting and my buddy Scotty,
he was saying something about a bad call was well look,
like from one angle it looked like it could have been a little premature,
but then from the final angle they showed it.
I completely agreed with it.
He went,
he flat lined,
he went out,
he got back up.
He'll keep what even got woken up.
Maybe you know like he like he was out for like a split second it looked like
and then you know,
sometimes people say that a punch can wake you up,
but I don't think that that makes a lot of logical sense.
But people do swear by it,
but I think it's just that you get hit as your body's kind of rebooting itself.
It probably will happen at the same time.
So it probably looks like this is my amateur neurology point of view.
But point is he got blasted Dan Henderson fucking put a whooping on him.
That's just no if,
ands or buts about
it.
It was all wild,
like minute and a half I think.
Throw down,
they would just swing in leather and Dan had,
they went to the ground and Dan Henderson hit this sweet wrestling reversal on
him where he was underneath him in half guard reaches up,
grabs a leg and ducks under and comes out the back door and just blast him with
an uppercut right in the jaw and fade or face plants,
bonk,
flatlines arms out and then Henderson blasts and twice in the back of the head,
I can like the side,
I don't know if it was illegal,
look,
look legal to me it was,
it was borderline though.
Anyway,
whatever it is,
he was done.
Anyway,
Henderson's winning this fight,
he's blasting him and then they stopped the fight and then fado rolls over and
everybody was like premature stoppage.
And from one angle I agreed with it.
I said,
hmm,
that might be premature.
But then from the last angle,
I looked at it from where herb dean could see it,
the referee and his,
he's out,
he got nailed and then you see them face plant and he's out.
He hits him again and he hits him again and herb dean steps in and then he rolls
over.
So it looks like you have let him recover.
But he wasn't recovering.
I don't,
I think it was ultimately probably a good call,
but it's,
it's,
he's got to err on the side of caution when he sees a guy flatline like that and
he has to assume that guy's not going to recover.
Especially when a guy like Dan fucking Henderson is dropping hammers on your
head.
You know,
I say when you get hit,
especially in this side of it,
and then your,
your brain just bounces against your brain pan.
It's like,
it's not good to get hit anywhere in the head
one spot.
That's awesome.
Like,
Ooh,
hit me here please,
please.
I mean if you want to get hit anywhere,
I would say the forehead,
but the forehead can really fuck with your equilibrium.
Your mobile boom.
No,
it makes your balance go.
Yeah.
So does the temple temple flux with the equilibrium or as like a shot to the
jaw,
just like shuts everything off.
Just shuts the machinery off and the Lego shots
mouth.
Not y'all.
I got,
I got knocked off.
I got hit one time,
hit in the head and then I got hit.
I hit a bumper of a car that I hit the street,
Danielle.
Then my mans and them scooped me up after they all came to cause some bad ass
marine came out and challenged all of us.
We just kicked ass.
We thought we did and some older dude,
we were just a bunch of high school kids.
We kicked this dude's ass and that due to some older dude marine came out in,
in systematically kicked all of our assets.
That's what I mean.
You get hit by a car.
I know he hit me in the head and I hit the bumper of a car.
I just thought,
wow,
if the bumper of a car and hit the pavement and I guys scooped me up,
I never felt it.
I just went out lights.
Wow.
Keep shouting me.
But I almost glad he did because if I would've saw that thing coming up,
I still couldn't have done it.
I thought it was gonna get my ass kicked the other day with you.
Like there was just some guy screaming at pass in Pasadena like after a comedy
show after Joe Show and he was screaming for a tax or doing something nice.
So I went around the corner and started recording and with my camera and he goes
right in my face cause yo yo yo.
And I thought he was like going to hit me and I'm like I hate,
I don't see you later.
And then suddenly he's like,
no,
you come here,
you come here.
And then he looks up and there's like everybody from the comedy club was
watching.
So it was like 30 people in this alley all staring at him and he looks up like
he was going to like,
you know,
do something to me.
And then he looks up and sees like 30 people staring,
watching the whole,
we were just walking towards it.
Yeah.
We were walking towards you because you,
you got ahead of us because we heard the screams.
Oh,
so we're all set.
We're all hanging out after the show or we hear the screaming at the Ice House.
We hear the screaming on the street like we think like maybe there's a fight
going on or something.
So we start walking.
Brian starts running and he runs with the camera,
but we're all walking behind him.
And then this guy got like super douchey with Brian.
Like I didn't know where like was like,
no,
you're not going anywhere.
And then he turns and saw all of us walking towards it and there's like 20 or 30
people.
It was,
the grade is like,
I like the word that's come back.
Oh yeah.
You don't want to,
you know,
see,
I have 30 people walking away going,
Oh really?
Dick?
Yeah,
right.
Shows,
clank and bottles together quickly.
He was one of those guys that was super eager to meet me before the show started
to,
there's certain guys that just have this weird maniacal and need to shake your
hand.
It's not,
even though he came to the show,
he was the guy he was,
he was nutty before the show even started.
It was nutty and certain dudes of just,
you know,
some people,
most people,
they just want a friendly shake your hand.
Eight nice to meet you.
Just get it.
Some people just take your hand or like,
I just want to touch your soul.
I want to take so right next to you and then now you're like the DJ.
I talk,
right?
Yeah.
I got the script.
I'd love you to read.
Read my script.
There's a lot of people that just think they need to meet you and then once they
meet you,
they're going to get the script through and then all of a sudden they're going
to be boondock saints.
Yeah.
Especially it's on because it's like I'm the only guy who knows about you,
John.
How many do you have guys?
That wouldn't,
especially when you were on a Frank Kelly endo show,
did you have a guys that were coming to you with sit-com ideas and all kinds of
shit like that?
Well,
the worst is when people who aren't even in the business what?
Submit new ideas.
Hey,
I think I got an idea.
You don't work in the shop.
Why are you tying to talk shop to me?
Hey,
I'll run this by you.
you should use this and your back.
You should shut the fuck up.
I had a friend that goes,
I would like to have you listened to my ideas,
but I'm going to need you to sign some paperwork first.
He actually said this cause his fucking idea.
I'm telling you,
it's not that they don't trust you.
It's because these ideas are so good.
Oh my God.
I go,
dude,
you can't pay me enough to listen to your fucking,
what are you talking about?
Oh,
I'm going to go sign paperwork with you.
You crackpot.
Go,
go do your thing,
man.
Can do patent work done.
Sign that shit.
Have your new soap.
Fix the world.
Fucking idiot.
Crazy assholes.
But that's,
that's this.
This part of the world is like people think that they're going to hit this one
thing and boom,
that's going to change everything.
This is happy when instead of grinding,
yeah,
no one down here knows how to get that.
Everybody wants the haymaker the fuck down and lands from kicking off the fence.
And the one punch knockout.
No,
the grind is where the beauty is should,
that's where the fucking human spirit has shown.
He's slowly pieced together a mother fucking empire.
Lockhart's speaking to empire,
where can all these fine folks see the Great Freddie Lockhart perform?
Uh,
thanks to you Joe Rogan.
They can listen to my podcast
podcast brought to you by talking.
Talk to you at [inaudible] dot com.
That's my new website.
That's my new product.
What does it say it again,
Mike?
Talking token.
He taught them and tow.
Okay.
Explain it to my new sponsor on my show.
Scotty.
Gee,
my good guy who got me turned onto the weed and good music and good times,
uh,
invented the talk and talk and it's great for anybody wants to get high.
It's a sponsor,
my show.
I won't talk about it too much since you got your own sponsors,
but that's going to talk about it.
Go ahead man.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and what it is,
it's like a hook,
a hose at the bottom of it.
It's a bowl and you can put it in your mouth while you probably didn't smoke it.
It kicks ass against when the elements of your skiing up in Colorado,
if you're at the beach.
So it's just a long tube along who could hose with a wooden handle.
And then at the endorsing this,
did you say while you're driving,
did you really just say that absolutely dead?
Why would you ever want to get behind a product that you're trying to sell and
you're saying who's this and drive?
No,
I'm not saying use this and drive.
I'm saying drive while you're girlfriend license.
That's what I'm going to show.
Come on.
What do you think?
I'm new and you think I was born yet?
Ecru to be saying this on the radio.
Internet.
So cast thingy.
So anyway,
I didn't save you put pot in there.
It's for cigarettes.
Not everybody should be doing that.
Yeah.
Not everybody should do that.
Like everything else.
Can't even handle jerking off.
How about that?
They can break things.
They can choose their jobs because they can't stop jerking off at work about
that.
Right.
And then come see me at the comedy store.
Do you ever come back?
That'd be great.
Possible.
I know you won't.
Can't happen.
You're a man of your word every weekend at the comedy store.
Listen to the podcast.
Could Fray lockhart.com they're pretty Lockhart podcasts on desk squad is
called.
Good.
What's done?
How many weeks or days a week you're doing this?
We're doing it once a week.
Once a week.
Yeah.
Powerful.
This Wednesday we have one more podcast rocking with,
uh,
my friend Chris who changed his fucking name,
Chris a used to be the guy from the flashlight and he quit working for the
flashlight and started on it labs and on it is on it.com o n n I t.com.
And that's the company that we're working with and we're putting together this
Alpha brain package.
It fucking works for real.
It's not snake oil.
Yeah,
I just got a couple of new bottles.
It's not snake oil.
I know.
People are like,
you know why it's,
what are you selling?
Like,
look,
I have a very small stake in this and I,
I really,
really believe in it.
What it is is nutrients for your brain.
It's really that simple.
It's all scientist based common goals and fucking testing test has been done and
Paco binds in order thing that's known to work,
you know,
into one pill.
So you're not having 5,000 pills to take.
There's plenty of evidence on the Internet about there's various supplements
that you can take that increased mental function.
You know,
I know,
um,
the football player,
a Roman ASCII bill,
Rowan Ascii is that his name,
a Broncos.
Roman ASCII had a,
um,
a company called neuro one and I took their shit and it's,
it really works and it's like,
it,
it makes you,
it gives you this heightened sense of awareness.
And I found that I could access information easier.
I've found that my memory work clear.
I found that,
uh,
I felt like I was a little bit more creative.
Like my thoughts were flowing and I don't know what these substances do exactly.
Other than that,
I know that they're all herbal and that they're all,
you know,
they've basically been proven throughout the years to have a subjective effect
on people's consciousness.
Yeah,
and you know,
I,
I told you,
I just took a couple of the other night,
but I was able to get into that link still and meditation mode that I normally
find very hard to get into.
The amazing for dreams.
It gives me the most incredible dream.
Yeah.
I don't take it at night because I don't want to have these nutty fucking take
it in the morning.
I took it at night,
but I fall asleep awake.
So I took that and it was fucking awesome and it's great for jet lag when you,
when you fly into some new place,
that's when it clears the cobwebs out.
I popped three of those bad boys consciousness.
I'm signs cards,
Alpha brain,
it's all gone.
I,
it's,
you can only preorder right now and we'll have Chris on,
on [inaudible].
I'm not calling them Aubrey.
Come on.
What have in him,
I change his name.
This is homeboy went to,
you're going to love this podcast is going to be a lot of fun because he's a
brilliant guy.
I love him to death.
He went to Peru and drank from the vine.
He went and had a shamonic experience.
Several of them drinking IOWASCA and he had some sort of an a revelation that he
needed to restart his life by changing his name or he murdered somebody and has
named his middle name,
middle name.
Either gain or something,
you know,
should I Alaska,
which is,
you know,
literally that's the spirit shit.
That's basically DMT in a,
in an oral form.
It's the most intense experience you can have supposedly told me about that.
I'm scared to try it.
You should be,
but he's going to come out on Wednesday and explained to us why it took on a
girl's name and tell us in that Wednesday will be when this shit will be for
sale.
If you don't like it,
don't buy it.
I,
if you can't afford it,
don't buy it.
I don't want anybody spending any money that they don't want to spend.
I don't want you to a,
I don't want you to ever think that you know that advertising should ever really
work on you with any shit like this.
But what I am telling you is it as a product,
I think there's some merit to this.
I think it's a,
it's a,
it's a strange combination of nutrients and together and conjunction and when
they work together synergistically,
I think it has an effect on your mind.
I feel it,
you feel too full bars.
That's what it does.
I think it's Legit,
you know?
And I think it's probably also one of those things that in time as you continue
to do it,
it's like when you take vitamins,
like I noticed for me at least,
if I stopped taking vitamins for like a week or so,
I take them,
I start taking them again.
I'll feel good for one day and then I'll feel better the next day and then I'll
feel a little bit better and I feel a little more even and I'll feel a little
more energy.
I feel a little more,
I feel better,
more with time.
So if I'm consistent with vitamins,
if I,
you know,
I get lazy sometimes and I'll take a couple of days off.
But if I'm real consistent after five or six days,
that's when I really start to feel subjectively.
I really start to feel the effect.
Like I feel energetic.
I feel really healthy right now.
I think a lot of it has to do with a really balanced diet and getting all my
nutrients in order.
I think that's the same with this shit.
Cause as I've taken it,
the more of taking it more days in a row,
the more I start feeling like really tuned in man.
Cause it's like you get your mind,
body and soul and once you get all those three things hit and it's so seldom we
have it like that,
that that,
but if you can find that balance,
man,
shit,
soul is a silly word is a funny one.
It's like what are,
what are we even talking about here?
No one can agree.
I like that.
I don't want to call it greens down with waffles and chicken together.
They're delicious combination brisket Nigga,
what?
It's not a fig Fogo de Chao at the mall.
I liked that place.
It's good.
The fake one at the malls.
Not Bad.
The two [inaudible] my friend,
um,
August 13th,
I'm in Milwaukee at the PAPP's theater.
There's still some tickets available for that.
That's going to be a lot of fun.
I'll be bringing Joey Diaz with me to Milwaukee.
I haven't been back to Milwaukee and a long time,
but I'm looking forward to going there.
And it's a,
they're having a UFC there too and that's the home of,
uh,
the Rufus camp.
One of the best when we tie a camps in America is a out of Milwaukee and they
also have a lot of guys will fight in the UFC.
Pat Barry fights with them.
Anthony Pettis fights for them.
So Milwaukee's a,
a bad ass town to have a UFC and to do comedy there.
So yeah,
I've loved doing that.
That's,
there's nothing more fun for me than when I do like a weekend where I do stand
up one night and then the UFC is the next night.
It's like,
really fuck.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'll hook them up.
Okay.
So that's a August 13th in Milwaukee at the PAPP's theater.
Can't fucking wait for that.
Joey Diaz is coming with me.
If you have never seen Joey Diaz before,
he's bringing the thunder.
September 23rd Joey Diaz and I are at the paramount theater in Denver,
Colorado.
Um,
and tickets are selling fast to that.
So a hop on that shit.
The paramount theater,
we tried to bring him to a,
the comedy works,
but Joe,
he's banned from the comedy works cause something naughty.
He did back in,
it's open mic days when he was struggling and clawing and scratching.
And so he's a,
he's banned from the franchise.
He can't work.
The company works.
So we have circumvented system and brought him into the paramount theater.
DENVER,
Colorado.
I bring you Joey Diaz.
What the fuck?
Cock suckers.
You got to see Joey Diaz at one time in your life.
It's like I got to see Kennison live when I was a kid.
You know,
you need to see Joey Diaz live.
That's September 23rd Denver,
Colorado.
Holla at your boy.
So we'll be back next,
this Wednesday,
this upcoming Wednesday with a my friend Chris Marcus who wants me to call him
Aubrey.
But that shit ain't happening and he's going to tell us all about how he went to
the jungle and took on a girl's name.
And I think what we need to do is,
uh,
I think Iowasca gave him a girl's name.
Jack Daniels.
Give him a fucking man's name.
We're going to route,
we're going to take them out.
We're going to give us some shots and we're going to get them to a band,
that girlie name and come up with something better like bolt.
This is your new name.
Lunch.
My name is Rod.
What do you mean?
Yeah,
granted.
All right folks,
you know,
you know we love you bitches.
Big Kiss.
See everybody soon.
Oh and thanks to the flashlight.
If you go Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the fleshlight and enter into codenamed Rogan.
You will get 15% off the number one sex toy from men and you will shoot your
loads and they have a good jolly old time.
Add a discount.
How the fuck does it get any better out there?
Keep on rocking in the free world.
Godspeed.
Big kisses to all.